representative soloway is out
today if if he's
wait if there's a seat filler he's out
all day if
your caucus in your office did not see
representative klein knight we're
waiting we have a busy schedule please
thank you so much members of the health
and human services committee for hearing
me today
as you've heard i've been here before
for
many mental health reasons
the
data that i'm showing to you shows that
we allow 12 year olds and up to seek
substance use disorder treatment without
a parent's consent that's a federal law
and if you look at the charts you'll see
all these 50 states that allow this 10
treatments without a parent's consent
14 years and up and i'm simply asking
for talk therapy which is the least
invasive treatment there can be now
um in the bill you'll notice that there
may need to be an amendment
to just say talk therapy
because
we don't want
any
drugs being prescribed without a
parent's permission
we can all agree on that and we also
don't want any
nefarious things going on such as
forcing a child to
transition without a parent's consent as
well so
we're simply asking for the least
invasive which is just talk therapy
since we already allow
12 year olds to go seek therapy
basically but they have we're basically
sending a message that they have to be
addicted to substances first and i think
we should get ahead of that
um on december 7th you'll notice
the united states surgeon general
published their findings on youth mental
health for the country
the published statement is a wake-up
call to our state and the rest of the
nation while mental health challenges
have continued to escalate among youth
for the past decade the pandemic has
only exacerbated this issue
i don't know if you want to start
writing some stuff down but here we go
before the pandemic one in five children
ages 3 to 17
struggled with mental health
in the last decade high school students
who reported feelings of hopelessness
increased by 40 percent that is more
than one in three students
there was a 36 36 percent increase in
seriously considered suicidal thoughts
and a 44 increase in having suicide plan
between 2007 and 2018 suicide rates
among youth ages 10 to 24 in the u.s
increased by 57 percent
in new hampshire suicide is the second
leading cause of deaths for ages 10 to
34 year olds
seeking help in the granite state has
children and families waiting two to
three weeks for inpatient treatment
the average amount of
children waiting in the er has increased
to 23 children
a day quadrupling the number that was
averaging six children waiting before
the pandemic
on october 19th you'll see the american
academy of pediatrics also declared a
state of emergency around mental health
for children and their families
as of june 2021 kovit has claimed the
lives of many parents and guardians
affecting the lives and mental health of
000 plus children
nationwide the pandemic has most heavily
affected those who are already
vulnerable such as youth with
intellectual and
developmental disabilities
racial and ethnic minority youth lgbtq
plus youth youth from families with low
incomes youth in rural community
communities and immigrant households
youth involved in the justice foster
care and or child welfare systems and
runaway youth and youth experiencing
homelessness per the surgeon general's
publication
we understand and recognize as one of
the nation's oldest states working to
attract young families that we need to
focus on services that address the needs
of the younger generation that includes
mental health care
that is why
we have i've made a commitment to
reimagine health care for the state
i come before you today pleading with
that this legislative body to pass this
bill as the evidence shows this is
merely a housekeeping bill to combat
this health emergency some of the policy
initiatives you've heard include setting
up a mental health drop-in center
allowing great granite staters to keep
their counselors who are out of state
and now this lowering the age a minor
can seek counseling
we need to show as a unified body that
we see you the children and families of
new hampshire
we see we know and we see you we hear
you and we will do everything in our
power to combat this crisis and end the
when i was 12 years old in middle school
my best friend was raped by her father
when i was 13 years old one of my
friends started sex working
when i was
14 years old my gay friend almost
commits suicide because
his parents didn't
accept him and school didn't either
my best friend through middle school and
high school
was on assistance but her father used
all the money for alcohol and she
couldn't even get a winter coat
these are the children
these are the same children that have
the same stories today
because
nothing really has changed and the
her nami director ken norton there's a
um
article there as well about the
inpatient waiting times
and i i just want to
close with
that if there is a
budget
issue the human services division
there is
finance
members of the body that are willing to
work on this issue but if you can see
per the rsas that i showed you that
allow 12 years old and sti treatment to
happen
we could this bill could be as simple as
just housekeeping those two statutes and
putting in talk therapy
as a reasonable
request
so i open
up to questions and
i will allow this body to see what they
can do with this any way they can
thank you and any questions for the
representative
i don't know if this is working is it
yeah uh thank you for taking my question
um
you know as
i'm really sympathetic to the uh you
know to you your cause here i've got a
30 year old nephew that committed
suicide a year ago
and uh my my big problem with this is uh
would you believe
that uh 50 of all all doctors and
psychotherapists and all that graduated
from the
graduate at the bottom half of that
class
and the parents need to have need to
you know need to need to be able to
um thank you i'm a little bit um
confused i apologize representative are
you saying that
you it's okay for 14 year olds to have
um sti treatments without a parent's
consent and have substance use treatment
disorder at age 12 but it's not okay to
get talk therapy
i i think that i think parents should
have
have uh
uh you can't ask him a question
a point of clarification then i'm sorry
what i i believe the parents should have
have
some have all say
i guess that's not a question but thank
you
representative kanark
you for taking my question i just have a
question about the payment issue
um
in lines 12 to 14.
uh we lay out the
the bill lays out the idea that the
trading facility may build the insurance
as applicable
and then call payments paid from the
uncomplicated care fund
the concern i have is it was
are you aware that this will
the information will still get back to
the parent because they'll receive an
explanation of benefits okay so it's not
so much confidentiality just having the
financial
coverage
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question
i was a bit intrigued you said that
we're looking to reimagine our health
care system and i was just curious
where you're trying to take the
healthcare system here in new hampshire
i'm trying to do some housekeeping i
mean if we're allowing 12 year olds to
go seek substance use disorder treatment
which is counseling and other methods of
help and we're allowing 14 year olds to
go seek sdi treatments without their
parents permission and help which those
two things in my opinion are more
invasive than talk therapy
follow-up um my follow-up is that that
seems like housekeeping not reimagining
the healthcare system and you had made
that statement in your in the beginning
of your your statements i can strike
reimagining and just say housekeeping
thank you mr chairman
and thank you for taking this question
on page one
line 24 emergency services
am i correct to believe that you're
talking about
emergency services providing
therapy or talk therapy or whatever it
is
but you're not
you're not suggesting that hospitals
would actually be able to admit somebody
for mental health care
no i would not want to deny any
practitioner if there is a health
emergency to
um
assist in going to the emergency room
just like any other practitioner would
say on their voicemail if this is an
emergency please contact your nearest
emergency room i hope that it would it
would function as that
follow-up
okay so i think i understand so if this
would happen in an emergency room
allow somebody to
consent to those services at 16 years
old
but if i'm reading this correctly you're
not suggesting that this bill would
allow them to be admitted for
psychiatric services in that hospital if
they had a
if they had a psychiatric floor
i believe they would still need to get
parent permission to be admitted yeah
this is strictly for talk therapy
follow up
four second question follow-up question
is um
i'm looking on page two about the
uncompensated
care fund
medicaid and uncompensated care fund
which i have no understanding of
so
is there somebody following you who can
kind of talk specifically about what
that is and how it works and whether
this would actually
be a realistic way to pay for
some of these services
yes
as i stated
i i hope that this body can focus on the
policy and that there are finance
members
catherine rogers representative rogers
has committed to working on the budget
for this
specifically
and can maybe it cannot be here today
for health reasons as as you all
understand
often the policy and the finance are
intertwined and overlapping and this is
why i as chair of this speak with
the chair of finance division three on a
regular basis because of that overlap
so i don't see that the numbers here
um
with all due respect i was told by a
member in finance that
this could be looked at and managed and
if we're already paying for it
with the laws that i passed around
for
sdis and
substance use i'm sure that
again housekeeping we could add talk
therapy into those segments as well i
accept that thank you sorry
thank you mr chairman and i actually
have a question of the chair because as
as drafted it's very clear
that the intent of the sponsors
is to expend funds on this which makes
sense because it's a new service and i
wonder why there is no fiscal note
whatsoever attached to it
and i wonder if perhaps
lba could be
asked why there isn't because
for this to be
looked at by finance it has to be an
early bill and i don't think it's been
designated as an early bill unless i'm
mistaken
it is not
okay
um and and
i i think that's
it is of concern to me that that wasn't
thank you representative
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
i'm hearing
the
and i'm just saying this for
clarifications in case i'm not catching
it all
one of the reasons why you think a child
should be able to seek treatment
talk therapy
without parental consent is incest are
there other
reasons why
yes my personal reasons
i'll list them again
my best friend in high school was gay
and is gay and wasn't accepted by his
own parents so they could never he could
never talk about it you could never talk
about it in high school but was teased
anyways so never formally came out for
many years suffered many shames
my other friend started sex work around
12 years old in middle school
and another one of my friends was on
assistance
and her father was
substance use for alcohol and used all
their assistance money for that
so
with these cases you're going to find
that these parents
they
they it's not that they can't give
consent they're not even being parents
some of them
so how can we
help the kids that are living on their
own taking care of themselves
manage and cope with everyday
decision makings that
normal adults should be making not
children how can we provide them another
resource for the life that they've been
given already the hand that they've been
given
how can we just allow them somebody to
follow up now
um in the in the case of of
um incest
and in the case of the
uh father
who was drinking away all the monies
those two things i see is
are criminal events and i would imagine
that they would be having
a state caseworker
assigned to them
um
so
that that is part of i think the parents
would automatically be involved
um because you want to get that child
away from the the one parent that's or
sibling that's the problem
and so
those that i would
wouldn't it be better
prepare
and i know that teachers go through
training already to hopefully recognize
would it not be better to
help augment
that so that the parents can come in
if if it's for instance if it's um
a sexual orientation
i would think that
the parent being part of the counseling
would help that child more
um
because then that child would know
better how to
speak to their parents about this and
the parents then could learn more about
how to
see what their child's going through
so so many of these things i see the
parent
as being beneficial to the overall
counseling situation
of that child is
can you
thank you representative
i think um
you're talking from a place of of that a
parent should do things when i'm talking
from a place of reality where i've seen
parents don't do things and i am coming
from a background where there's not
enough caseworkers in our state and the
caseworkers we do have are overloaded
and that if you go talk to a parent for
20 minutes they can hide their problem
very easily to stay on assistance and
you're talking to children as a best
friend to all these people that don't
want to tattle on their family members
because
that they carry that because they don't
want anybody to get in trouble and have
it be them their fault and in also some
cases that if they were to go to foster
care it would be even worse for them so
it um i again i don't see the harm and
talk therapy when we offer so many other
invasive treatments without a parent's
consent
representative
would i be wise
to listen to one of my staff members
who's a family systems therapist
that secrets
are dangerous
and that it's sooner or later those
secrets come out in sometimes not a
controlled setting
that family systems talk therapy
is generally speaking far superior
but in those cases where the parent is a
bad actor we've got a more serious
problem going on here and needs some
kind of further intervention am i to
believe my staff member who says that to
me
you're to believe that
family counseling is very beneficial
that isn't a reason to take away
personal therapy
and
again when family members can't make it
to family therapy there has to be
another option provided
representative leon thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking
another question
my question is about these these
children who are worried about getting
their parents in trouble my first
thought was that except in the case of
the sexuality these are all issues of
mandatory reporting so if they needed
access they could speak to one of their
teachers and fortunately it's a
different world than you and i grew up
in and now there's a lot of allies for
people in the school system for gender
issues so there is somebody that they
can go to when that is an issue within
the home my question to you is if the
concern is that that children are
avoiding care because they're worried
their parents will get in trouble that
doing this gives them false comfort and
might create a larger problem if they go
and do this talk therapy and then their
patient their parents have the have the
authorities called on them because of
their neglect or criminal conduct and if
those secrets leading to that could lead
to
a potentially very bad outcome in the
home
thank you so much representative um so
in in in the
event that a child does say stuff i
as representative folsom made quite
aware that we should actually have an
intervention if it is that bad and if
i did some research the only people they
can tell our school teacher or school
nurse it's not investigated and it's not
a steady flow of treatment and it's not
a support system that you can count on
and
so
when we're all we're very worried about
secrets and all these things we should
be worried about the numbers that are
increasing with committing suicide for
children because those are the real
secrets
that can't come back
so i think we need to try something new
here
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman uh so
uh going back to the
you know evidence-based practice of
involving the whole family in
talk therapy
that's the direction that dcyf has sort
of taken over the years they
the their first resort when even in
cases of abuse and neglect
they will try to bring in a therapist
in home
um to work with the parents and the
children
and i think for those cases where it's
the secrets are so severe that it would
warrant um further intervention that you
know those children would be removed
from that dangerous situation and could
um
continue talk therapy you know
unencumbered by the worry of the parents
so my question
is
um
you know how does when we have those
systems in place and the evidence is
that most most children benefit from the
parents being involved in that kind of
therapy
how does that um
you know how does that uh justify
removing the rights of parents of most
children
you know
to be aware and to consent to such
treatment
thank you so much representative cushman
i would think that if
a really healthy family
or
aim to be healthy a very caring parent
parental figure
would always want to do what's best by
their kid
and would always
make sure that they have the best care
available to them
and if they for whatever reason didn't
feel comfortable going to them
they would want them still to get the
care that they needed and that is
exactly what i've heard from most of the
parents in my district
and again when you have a family that's
so involved that's rarely the case where
a kid would go off and need to seek this
service
but there is a reason why our numbers of
child suicide are increasing and i think
that
it would shame us to not try something
new
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i have a couple
one is are you aware that parents who
have often had their children removed
because of serious issues
still have the right to object
under current law
so a child who needs
needs counseling
is not permitted
i
i didn't have to deal with dcyf when
when i got divorced but my ex was so mad
about my son going to a counselor he
sued the counselor so counselor was
afraid to see him anymore so he said he
couldn't so i can see the need for this
kind of this kind of law especially
since
i guess i'm curious as to why you chose
16 maybe that's already part of the
current law because that's pretty old
if i've had it my child wasn't 16 at the
time when he needed he represented to
finish the question and let the
representative answer please um thank
you representative gay um yeah i i
brought this bill in 2020
and i had it for 12 and i pleaded with
the committee
before this body as i am here today and
requested that we have something and
something's better than nothing and that
if if whatever you felt was more
comfortable to passing if that meant
raising the age then i would do it but i
do believe it should be 12 because all
the things that i said
that is
12 years old is when those things start
to happen
but again 16 is better than nothing
are we too um suspect i mean excuse me
wrong word are we to expect
that should this bill pass you will be
back with another bill
um lowering the age
to 12. i hope so okay thank you
yes mr chairman thank you for calling on
me this is actually a question for you i
was just wondering if there was a pink
card from someone at the department of
health and human services that might
help us understand the uncompensated
care and medicaid fund there does not
representative mckay
mr chairman
sorry to be late and miss your early
part of your testimony
several different pieces of legislation
are doing the same thing and that is
adding additional professional
mental health professionals
and
do you have any thoughts as to where
these people are going to come from
because at this point
all of these mental health facilities
are
looking for
the existing
organization are looking for staff
and this adds on to that list
and thank you for
your concern thank you representative
you're absolutely right which is why i
was before this body fighting for people
to keep their out of state mental health
professionals
now will counsel the extra people
needing counseling in our state
that reduces the number of counseling
spots available in their state does it
not
it does not especially
since you're over telehealth if you have
an open slot and you can virtually help
somebody all over the world i don't see
how
we would be
how they would be losing slots
maybe they have a better funded mental
health statewide program so they have
more mental health practitioners and
they have enough to share
so you would would you be suspecting
then that there are some states where
there's so many mental health counselors
they have time to spare and could um
telehealth are people is that your
suspicion and i think that the um
a member of health and human services
department said that around 42 of our
new hampshire citizens are relying on on
out-of-state mental health care
providers via telehealth
thank you
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman would you believe
that after practicing as a
psychotherapist for over 30 years in new
hampshire
and
attending countless ethics um
conferences where this kind of thing is
where the age of consent is discussed
and after recently contacting the
director of um adolescent services and
the ceo of my
local
community mental health center that
after all that i am still not clear on
the age of consent as it currently
stands without this bill
and would you agree that
this would provide some clarity about
whether people 16
and 17 would be able to access services
on their own thank you so much
representative and um thank you for
sending me that question
earlier as well
yes this is with all due respect we
should be protecting our own
health care professionals as well if
there isn't if there's a a
just an ambiguous dark hole where a law
should be
we're putting the state at risk we're
putting the professionals at risk we're
putting the families at risk and the
children at risk we're doing nobody any
favors by continuing to ignore
anyone else representative cushman
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um is there any risk to
having children
alone behind closed doors with an adult
who their family doesn't know when their
family doesn't know that they're there
thank you so much representative cushman
um i think
yeah any closed door between i would say
yes
if you just for clarification you're
talking specifically about licensed
therapists though
um via telehealth i i don't think if
they're a trusted
member in their own state
under the same licensing rules as we
heard earlier last week that there
should be concern
and
hopefully you know that these children
are getting treated for what they're
trying to see somebody for
but as someone that was put in a private
room with a teacher and threatened i can
tell you that
sometimes you don't always trust
the adult and you need to go somewhere
else
thank you and and first of all i just
like to say that i really appreciate
your continuing efforts to bring to
light
the huge need that there is out there
for care
for people who are not receiving it so
that's item number one
uh with regard to the specifics of the
bill and i think this is a conversation
we had last time as well and i'm still
the bill provides that the facility
it provides that let's see
uh
the parent or legal guardian shall not
be liable to pay for any treatment
pursuant to this section which is good
because they didn't contract for it so
they don't have to pay for it
but
my concern is the part about if the
miner is current under a parent or
guardian's insurance the treating
facility may build that insurance as
applicable
and my concern is that if things between
the parent and the child
are so broken that this child needs
assistance without the parents
involvement which indicates a pretty
high level of dysfunction on the
parental side
isn't it very risky
to have
an insurer stepping in and then
the parents getting an explanation of
benefits
which arrives at the home
at a time when there aren't other
safe people around
that i'm still wrestling with that and
how do you envision that playing out and
how do we safeguard
the confidentiality
part of the minor's care
um thank you so much representative
weber since that was a main point of
contention and the last time i brought
this bill forward was payment which is
the only reason why i put that in there
to alleviate the burden off of the state
but
i believe that you're right the privacy
would outweigh the burden and the state
should
be able to provide for a child that is
suffering that amount and i would be
amenable to amending that out
thank you
follow up yes i just had one other
question because we have
i have heard the use term talk therapy
used
and i have heard the word counseling
used and i just wondered is there a term
of art that we should be using
when we want to specify that this child
is talking to an adult but the adult is
not prescribing
for the child
yes i believe that a definition would be
very valuable and that is again i
brought up at the beginning
that it's
since we we don't want providers giving
children medication you know without
parental consent that that should be
defined
i agree to that
i i did the best i could i'm not a
lawyer
that is a bad excuse but
i did try to change it and address a lot
of the concerns that were brought
forward the first time i brought this
the chair recognizes representative
megan murray who is a co-sponsor of the
bill
thank you for the record my name is
megan murray i represent the district of
um hillsborough 22 that is amherst
and i come before the body as not only a
legislator but a parent
and one of the things that i would like
to say
regarding this is the experience that i
had
again sitting before the members of a
roundtable discussion in milford new
hampshire
last year hearing folks similarly aged
that would be addressing this bill who
were around 16 years of age
many of the things that they shared with
us at that listening session did
stem
from a desire to have the ability to
independently
seek care whether it was peer support or
their own ability to seek
um
talk therapy
in the event most 16 year olds at this
point have the ability to drive work
have a job
and are are becoming independent members
of their communities
and preparing for
graduation or grad school or trade
schools
and i do believe
that
just like there would be an ability to
seek treatment for sti
treatments or sud which oftentimes does
have a mental health component to it
that this makes good sense
to allow
adolescents 16 years and older
to be able to seek
and as a parent
i
also um
see that there are
situations where
[Music]
my child or another
had as had been testified to in in
milford at the round table discussion
where an individual seeks an outside
independent
third party person to bounce something
off of that they are going through
um
and to that end i do seek that they're
like that this would be one
viable option to allowing
those who are 16 and older to be able to
do so and i'll happily take any
questions
representative you mentioned various
things that a 16 year old can do such as
drive and hold a job
how many of those are truly
independent that is they live on their
own they pay all the bills or are they
not under the roof protection and
probably legal liability of their
parents
so we're not quite as independent just
because one can drive and have a job are
we
thank you for the question
well to your point i i do
agree that there is a certain level of
independence well yet not being fully
independent i do agree to that however
um
there are many situations where
those who are of that age are in
situations that may require them
to
that they have experiences outside of
the home and their family that might
require that they need to seek
treatment or therapies
and so for that it's simply asking for
talk therapy it's not asking for
medication in the event that there would
they would then
have to make that decision to notify
families i am assuming if it required a
representative leon
thank you mr chair
sorry thank you mr chairman and thank
you for taking the question
would you believe that in the state of
new hampshire
somebody who is under 18 requires
parental permission to get a driver's
thank you for the question i
do believe that that is the requirement
but yes i i also do believe that in the
situations where
somebody's health and mental health is
healthcare
is in need of being addressed i think
we should be making every effort to
allow that to be as barrier-free as
possible
hello there we go
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
i know you can go online and download
uh
apps for talk therapy
can you please
tell me how they
go about
keeping it in
with the laws of each state do they do
they
like if i tried to get on as a 12 year
old would they stop me from being able
to access the help that's
given on the app
thank you
um i'm
i'm not entirely sure of the question
when you said they
the people who run the apps
i'm not a website or content developer
so i do not know how that would exist in
that framework
follow-up
so if they are available online and you
can download an app what would stop a
minor from being able just to get the
therapy
again
to your point i
i do not know how many apps are
available out there and we're not just
specifically talking about telehealth
talk therapy so
yeah this is getting off the point about
a minor receiving health treatment
without parental consent
interesting question
i'm going to say this thread
no
any other questions
representative gay
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question are you
would you agree
that the teens who need this bill
do not have the protection of their
parents
and
school counselors are not necessarily
trained in more than counseling about
school
thank you representative for the
question i do agree
that there are individuals seeking
further treatments in care who are 16
years of age or older
and i do agree that there are
circumstances in which school counseling
they're seeking
clarity and care outside of the school
counseling setting
thank you mr chair and else thank you
for taking the question um i noticed
inside of the list of places this can
occur one of the places that i think
may want to be considered
is the school itself there are school
psychologists and so forth that exist
but in the bill here is written that has
been left out if you look at line
and eight i think
the public schools any school system
if they also have the ability to treat
would that be something that
we should consider
thank you for the question um so
to that end i did i want to go back
again to the very
eye-opening experience that i had
hearing individuals in milford new
hampshire
who did
some of them were school counselors some
of them were school social workers who
also stated that there was a large need
to expand resources and options
available for
follow-up or second question
again clarification on the question or
clarification
are you saying we should or should not
add schools to the list of facilities i
think it makes sense that that if that
is a
first step
for an individual seeking care or
clarity
but there are often times where it
seeing no more hands up thank you
representative thank you
the chair recognizes emma sevigny from
good morning and thank you for having me
today and thank you for your time to
hear such an important bill
um
for the record my name is emma savini i
am here as the children's behavioral
health policy coordinator from new
futures new futures is a non-partisan
nonprofit organization that advocates
educates and collaborates to improve the
health and wellness of all granite
staters
i'm here in support of this bill
as you've heard i believe there are some
amendments that may make it a stronger
bill but the spirit of it and the
underlying policy is important and
should be supported
new futures supports house bill 1409
because it is clear that youth need
access to mental health care treatment
to ensure that they are healthy and safe
um in new hampshire 15.08
of youth have reported having a major
depressive episode in the past year this
is higher than the national average
it's clear from these numbers that that
minors and teenagers in this instance
would benefit from having mental health
treatment access
without parental consent if their
parents are not supportive
um there is clearly
a as the surgeon general mentioned and
as representative klein knight mentioned
in her testimony
and an epidemic of mental health crisis
in
across the nation and in new hampshire
it is clear that we should be removing
boundaries and barriers to receiving
treatment
and so this is one way that children
should be or could be able to receive
treatment without their parents consent
if their parents are not supportive
[Music]
access to mental health care treatment
supports the overall overall health and
well-being of a child or
in this instance a teenager
and would provide long-term better
outcomes
when treatment is available early on
it's more effective and typically
better long-term outcomes than if
treatment is
given at a later stage in a mental
health crisis or
diagnosis
as proposed this bill would help improve
the
um health and wellness wellness of new
hampshire's youth um and any amendments
i'm i'm happy to review and and provide
comment on later but i believe as the
bill is written the spirit of it
should be considered and supported by
this body thank you and i'm happy to
take any questions
any questions
representative acton
thank you mr chair
and uh thank you for taking my question
uh we've certainly heard compelling
testimony that there's a need for uh
greater access to um mental health care
for youths
i guess the there's a disconnect though
because the issue at hand here is
parental rights
and at what point does the problem
outweigh the problem of
of
students being blocked from access
by parents
how big of a problem is it do we have
any
uh information on how any statistics on
children who report that their parents
won't let them get that because it seems
to me that
yes we need to provide access so um but
is there really a problem other than the
worst case scenarios that we're pointing
out from from over our life experience
is there really a problem with parents
blocking access to mental health care
for their children
thank you so much for your question
representative i don't have specific
specific statistics on that issue um but
i'm happy to review and see if i can get
some for you
um i think i'm also not a representative
so i don't have constituents that i
speak to on a daily basis but i think we
should hear from the representatives who
have spoken and said that this is an
issue in their communities
and understand that this is probably a
more widespread issue than we realize
anything further
thank you counselor uh sorry
representative woods
uh uh thank you mr chair and thanks for
taking my question um just uh uh some
idea uh or
can you provide us an idea about uh
any rule that might be already in place
uh say a child
comes um talks about a particular
problem uh about how long that can go on
or is there within the
statute or code of ethics for the
profession
saying that they can only see them once
or twice and then they must notify or is
there anything internal
that would terminate or
impact that ongoing care
thank you so much for your question um i
am not aware of any rule that currently
exists in the mental health
practitioners
rules um or in the state
rsas that that
handle that problem but that's
potentially something we could support
thank you counselor for your testimony
thank you
the chair calls upon state
good morning mr shared and members of
the committee my name is
instead representative maria perez i
represent milford
at district 23 and i'm here to
testify in opposition of this bill
i've been
in some of the round tables in milford
since i represent milford
yes i'm i'm aware that we have a crisis
for mental health
but i don't think this bill is going to
help us to solve the issues that we have
and my other concern is that a lot of
towns around milford
they don't have
ambulance systems they don't have ent
services
over area
and
my concern is how about any of these
kids
in these
areas where they don't have
these medical assistants
how about if any of these kids that they
get
a crisis because of the medication
sometimes
even adults we can develop an um
worse sentence when medication
in
these
towns in in the rural areas they don't
have those
um
those systems that they need so for me i
believe um
we need to consider those things too
and um i feel like this is like um
putting
doctors and pharmacies in the risk to
lawsuits because
taking away a lot of the rights from
parents
as a parent
i get it you know a lot of kids you know
they don't have the same relationship as
you know i i had with my kids growing up
but but i think this is not the solution
for that reason i i oppose this bill
would you take a question or two for
sure would you
in your opinion believe
that this bill while it might provide
some short-term
help to some
un-strengthen the family system
yes
any other questions representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking the question
it sounds like you're saying that
there's a lot of other problems that are
creating barriers to access to care and
do you think it's more important to look
at those before we look at breaking
those parent-child bonds for sure you
know it is incredible um you know to to
take the time to learn you know that
maybe we need to to help these families
to build the relationships that they
need and um
we know that we need more social workers
we know that we we have more um mental
health um
doctors and in in hospital they have a
crisis of beds and stuff like that so
those are the areas that i believe that
we can work on
instead of then try to get those parents
rise away from them or like you know
instead of then help and to build a
relationship taken away from from those
relationships that in the future you
know we want to have kids that they can
be able to come to the parents and be
able to be open and have those
relationship but
for me i feel like this has taken away
that
that moment that we that we need as a
parents to build relationship with our
kids
thank you you're welcome sing no further
questions thank you representative
the chair calls upon john williams from
dhhs we had asked earlier is there
anybody from dhhs who might provide
information
i qualify for one of the two
um you are from dhhs that is correct you
are also a wealth of information i i i
will try to be
um so um chairman pearson and members of
the committee thank you for the record
my name is john williams i'm the
director of legislative affairs and uh
hp 1409 comes before you obviously the
bill sponsors are working to try to gain
greater access to certain mental health
treatment for for certain minors however
my commentary here today is specific to
starting on page three or rather page
two uh starting on line three which uh
starts section three of the bill on
uncompensated care and medicaid fund
you're probably aware that the
department working along with the
important hospitals out there identified
either uninsured or medicaid where
there's uncompensated care to
try to do our best to providing needed
resources to critical access hospitals
and hospitals in nature so essentially
what you see starting on line three all
the way down to the bottom of page 34 is
existing law and the reason why they had
to do that is to show the proper
placement for the one amendment to this
section or rather to the um subparagraph
of the bill and it's a very long
sub-paragraph so going to page three
the
text again all the way from sec from
lines 1 to 21 our existing law and you
can see all the specifics that they're
identifying for the use of uncompensated
care
the bills sponsor or at least the office
of legislative services and and
providing uh for a
provision in a new roman subparagraph d
starting on line 22 through line 23
again so page 3 line 22 123 to pay for
deductibles copays and uncovered
services pursuant to the newly created
rsa 135 c 68 which is identified in
section 1 of the bill
of interest is that the department did
not receive from the legislative budget
assistance officer requested doing a
financial analysis nor did the
department of insurance for some of the
members of the committee who were here
in 2020 you may recall there was a very
similar bill
hb 1616
which was relative to
the
access
miners to to visit mental health
practitioners the bill was referred to
interim study before this committee
and but the department did was provided
an opportunity as well as the insurance
department to provide commentary on that
bill although that bill on a quick read
i don't believe had anything provisions
for uncompensated care we did identify
that there would be an increased
utilization expected as a result of
legislation and i think it's fair to say
without a more thoughtful analysis that
we'd anticipate greater utilization uh
under this legislation uh for for the
bill if it were to go forward the
question here though is mechanically how
would this work and would have benefited
us to actually have reviewed this and i
certainly can take it back to our
division for medicaid services director
lipman and his staff to find out what
the unintended consequences may be
but the devils are always in the detail
and the concern is around the mechanics
to pay for deductibles co-payment
co-payments and unins rather uncovered
services pursuant to the rsa
135 c 68 doesn't isn't clear to us
exactly how that would work since
currently it's designed specifically for
uninsured and medicaid
specific to making hospitals and related
facilities whole so
you can see mechanically where we would
have to really look into seeing whether
this does anything at all uh or how this
this would work um so with that that
concludes my commentary and like i said
at the beginning i could answer one of
the two questions i am here on behalf of
representative weber has a question for
thank you mr williams and
um
this has been a long process and a
really intractable one and i commend the
representative for sticking with it and
i understand her frustration having been
told the last time around
that there needed to be funding
mechanisms to now be told that the
funding mechanisms are have haven't been
reviewed because somewhere
between ols and lba there was a slip and
nobody was notified that this bill had
significant
fiscal impacts and significant insurance
impact
which is not her fault but
i think is
a reason for us to explore our systems
but
that's a long
prelude to the question which is
if we simply stripped out everything in
this bill except a sentence that said
minors may consent
at age 16
to receiving mental health services
providing such services
do not include medication which
was one of the big sticking points
what would the department's position be
at that point
and and reference weber thank you for
for the question
i would have to say that we would need
to see the specifics of the language to
provide you with a thoughtful response
to that commentary because i could just
make the
statement today that by removing section
three of the bill certainly you remove
the concern regarding the mechanics
behind the use of uncompensated care
i don't know how much further
uh beyond the other
folks who are
provider community for mental health
could probably better than i answer your
question on on trying to draw up a bill
that comports with
um law
and accomplishes a goal without
encroaching upon uncompensated care
if you wish i'm all set thank you very
much
representative shapiro
if we were to leave
section 3
in
i'm wondering since i know nothing about
the uncompensated care and medicaid fund
i'm wondering if that is
you said it was provided to hospitals
currently
is that provided to hospitals on an
aggregated basis
like not specific billing for specific
clients
and would this be
if that is the case would this be very
different
mechanism for people
for
[Music]
mental health clinicians actually
and chairman pearson in response to
representative shapiro's questions
the world of uncompensated care and
compensated funds and i have lived part
of the journey on watching legislation
is an extremely complex world and i am
definitely not the person you should be
having a conversation with on the
interplay between not only our agency
the hospitals as well as revenue rather
the department of revenue administration
also has a piece as you see embedded in
the rsa 84 i believe it's a d that's in
the section that's cited um i i know
director lipman
would probably be
in a good position to identify somebody
who you give you a high level tutorial
on uncompensated care but it is very
complex and very high level and beyond
the scope of what's in this bill today
thank you counselor thank you
we've got two final cards
and we're way over time the chair
warning
i am not a
co-sponsor elected rep or
directly involved in
the state house or government of new
hampshire just a
concerned parent
testifying about a bill that i think has
some real potential for good
if we can get out of our own way
to address a couple concerns and forgive
me for jumping around a little bit
but a lot has been said that i think
needs to be addressed
i am not a mental health expert i have
had limited
experience myself but i think
there are two sides to this from what i
understand there's the clinical side
and the uncompensated care side and i
did not plan on touching on that but
we'll very briefly
as somebody who does work uh
peripherally in healthcare and uh
there's a practical and political side
and i think the best place to start is
by clearing up some myths
that i think
are presumed in a bill like this in
terms of impact on family structure
number one family structure is a
personal thing it
exists at your kitchen
dinner table it exists in your living
room
it is not the government's role
to dictate what that looks like and i
think to use that as an excuse to
suggest that access to care is gonna
uh you know have a negative impact on
relationships between parents and
children is ignoring the fact that if
we've gotten that far those
relationships are already broken
if anything talk therapy is going to
strengthen those relationships these are
certified clinical professionals
who are obligated by law not to report
um any
content from those conversations unless
imminent physical harm
is uh you know is a reality for that
child i have an eight-year-old daughter
we're talking about 16 this should be a
12 or 14 year old
uh you know wave of parental consent
um
i would gladly let my eight-year-old do
talk therapy there is no damage in it
um you know that's like me saying that
if i put a rain jacket on
uh right now and walk outside i can
assume it's gonna start raining
not only is it not gonna rain
but if unexpectedly it did i would be
better equipped to not get wet
that's what talk therapy is and that's
what proactive pre-emptive mental health
care is
so we need to be real about that right
now and dispel the myths
this is not an encroachment on family um
this is about
extending the same liberties and
freedoms to our children that we would
sit here in this room and claim to
protect for ourselves
that doesn't make
sense to jump into a couple questions
that were asked um i think it was
representative
delemus
okay
i'm sorry um i i can confirm uh in
response to your question to
representative murray that
when you do a telehealth application or
digital application for mental health
there is a parental
consent form that is required and you
would be denied access to that unless
you forged it in which case uh you know
any number of mechanisms would be
triggered that would probably uh defeat
the purpose you know that we're all
after here
um
no worries um with regard to
the concern over uncompensated care
i mean this may sound crass but we have
a system in place for this when a child
shows up at the er unaccompanied by an
adult however rarely that occurs thank
god the child is treated often even
adults who qualify for new hampshire
health or medicaid and new hampshire are
retroactively enrolled when they have a
serious medical issue
which skirts what should happen but
that's the best we got sometimes because
we're not going to let people die on the
front steps of the emergency room nor
should we allow unnecessary suicide to
happen in new hampshire
so
with respect to someone who's not in
government and this may be easy for me
to say
if we're going to get in the weeds on
uncompensated care and medicaid
enrollment and eobs
um i would offer a suggestion that
perhaps a parallel um or follow-up
amendment should be uh you know explored
uh by the persons in this room and
sponsors on this bill to potentially um
create if it doesn't already exist and
might be a question for the gentleman
from health and human services um an
auto medicaid enrollment mechanism that
would occur uh for a minor
uh attempting to seek mental health care
services
um i also don't think
that the
costs and the impact on the health care
structure
suggested you know in this room i mean i
think you know what we're really after
you know you're looking at a couple
different scenarios here one is that or
maybe three scenarios
the worst case scenario which is um
the child is in realistically the
majority of the children who are
impacted by this bill
are probably part of a population who
are likely never going to get parental
consent
so we should tell the truth
um
in which case many of those kids may
already be enrolled in medicaid and new
hampshire
health um the other you know outcome
here is i think the concern that we hear
a little bit which is well there you
know we're going to have government in
our our living room and
you're going to have uh the salem witch
trials all over again and you know kids
are going to be crying wolf to cause you
know drama or rebel against their
parents
i mean
number one back to a prior point
if you follow that train of thought to
fruition it's not going to work that way
you know that's not the way clinical
mental health is built and number two
if that's the case and that kid needs
mental health treatment anyway you know
so
where are we at you know um
the the other you know thing that i can
see happening
um you know would be
god forbid greater access and
participation in
proactive brand of mental health and
that's actually good for everybody
um this is a suicide prevention bill
this is a bill that would you know if we
had better access in the state you know
we obviously have a serious staffing
uh shortage in terms of mental health as
well so we certainly should be accessing
um surplus of mental health care
providers in other states that's just
common sense you know the wait list in
so when we talk about also existing in a
state that is very unwilling to regulate
not only gun
possession
but but sale um certainly it's
unconscious going off topic and you have
one minute left fair enough but this is
very relevant especially if we're
discussing letting college students
carry on campuses then we should
probably
match it with mental health access
i'll finish up
so i think we've covered most of our
i think conflating the right to drive
with the right to health care
is a reach at best
and i will end with one statement
if you believe in liberty if you believe
in free speech including the freedom of
confidential speech to a therapist if we
believe in the right to pursue happiness
as it best suits our needs our goals our
dreams including for our children then
we must believe in those things for our
children
let's not be such foolish hypocrites
who would preach liberty but refuse to
practice it
in the same moment we fool ourselves
into believing it doesn't apply
the chair recognizes as our last person
speaking to the bill russen chester from
bedford
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members i will keep it brief
i am a former child protective service
worker in the state of new hampshire and
this bill is not only a violation of
parental rights um and
further destroys transparency and
working together cooperatively with
families but it also puts our children
at significant risk
the problem is is that
and i understand the
representatives intent behind the bill
but the reality is is that the parents
that are not going to consent
are the ones that we need to be worried
about those are the ones that when that
parent gets that letter in the mail
and says
you
what did you do why did you do this
where's the where's the
where's the support
telehealth
um the other thing with regards to
telehealth with regards to telehealth
and talk therapy you do not need a
master's degree in most of our
surrounding states to practice
telehealth therapy you do not need a
degree even a bachelor's degree in
psychology or social social um
understanding of child development
now i'm going to speak a little bit as a
parent
i had a stepdaughter who was
significantly traumatized in her very
young life
i took her out of that environment and i
i brought her into a really wonderful
environment my opinion she agrees still
to this day which is good
however
um
my stepdaughter
was
had what they call transference
so when she started going through
um when she started being exposed to
uh
the child education or um sex education
classes and things like that i was made
aware as the parent she chose to go
through those classes i expected that
there would be some fallout from it
um
i did not
identify her as a sexually reactive
child
or a child that had significant mental
health issues she was going to therapy
three days a week
because it was that significant
however the school system
saw certain behaviors because they had
eight hours of training on how to
recognize problems
they took it upon themselves to not only
call child protective services but to
put my step-daughter into an out-of-home
placement for three days
and during that time she was further
abused the bottom line is that's the
kind of thing that this bill does for
the children of new hampshire
i know that wasn't the intent
um
and uh but i just wanted to make sure
that you folks understood there was
another side and a significant
consequence to a bill like this
thank you so much for your testimony and
with that i closed the hearing on house
bill 1409
and let's take a minute or two breather
foreign
just
yes
wow
however
tv
right
uh
um
mr
john
opening the hearing on house bill
1126 permitting minors
over the age of 16 to obtain a
vaccination without parental consent the
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
hello
my name is amanda bolden i represent
hillsborough district 12 which is ward 5
in manchester
um i passed around an info packet with
just a few
items of interest related to the bill
and i'll go over that in a little bit
i just wanted to mention that there are
a lot of things that you can do without
parental consent in new hampshire once
you turn 16.
among them you can engage in sex acts
with a partner of any age you can become
pregnant you can impregnate another
you can raise your own child
you can obtain and use narcan to stop an
opiate overdose
you can seek and obtain a divorce you
can drop out of school
there's all sorts of things
you that you that we entrust
16 year olds to make an independent
decision on
in our state
um and these are things of much greater
inconsequential importance than an fda
approved vaccination
it's clear to me that people age 16 and
older can make an informed decision
about vaccination
this bill isn't aimed at parents who
will object to vaccination based on some
scientific or health concern
or due to religious preference but at
parents who will never consent because
they are unavailable to the child
in manchester it's estimated that there
are between 300 and 750 homeless
teenagers
there have been many situations in
recent years due in large part to the
opioid epidemic in which children are
effectively abandoned to manage their
own lives in the emotional and physical
absence of their parents
teachers in new hampshire schools have
seen many students who are unkempt with
overgrown hair clothes clearly in need
of laundering no access to a computer
for homework etc personally i serve on
the board of a non-profit that provides
winter coats to children all over new
hampshire
and there's a great demand every year
we have many programs in our state which
provide food to children every day so
that they can feed themselves over the
weekend
because their parents will not feed them
this type of program is referred to as
68 hours of hunger as this represents
the period of time that the child is out
of school over the weekend and thus
lacks access to food
during the early stages of the coveted
shutdowns when schools were completely
closed there was a massive effort in
manchester
and i imagine other towns to use the
school buses to deliver breakfast and
lunch around the city as thousands of
manchester children rely on school for
their meals on a daily basis
and of course i've yet to meet a child
who made it through remote learning
without failing multiple classes as the
support structure they needed as
students was unavailable to them at home
in our state if a child can obtain a
dose of narcan and deploy it on their
unresponsive overdosing parent they
should also be able to obtain a desired
and age-appropriate vaccine
i agree that there are many things that
a person age 16 should not be able to do
without parental consent
because those activities would be
harmful to them but if a teenager is
focused on their health and would like
to be vaccinated the law shouldn't stand
in their way
and some of the things
that i included in this packet
the bill for your reference
on the next page
a list of states that allow
minors to make health care decisions for
themselves related to vaccines
in varying degrees
also
a piece from the new hampshire bulletin
that specifically states that children
must have parental consent to be
vaccinated in new hampshire
and it specifies that a permission form
must be signed by a parent or guardian
if they're having their vaccine
administered in the absence of their
parent for example
at the mobile vaccine clinic that's
specified in the
in the article
the next piece that i shared with you is
an article from manchester inklink salem
police charged couple with
uh living in filth and squalor with
child endangerment in this particular
situation i guess these folks
i mean they're
innocent until proven guilty um but i
guess these folks had adopted multiple
children of varying ages
some of them 16 and 17
who were essentially completely
neglected
and were not unable to
get regular health care among other
issues and it wasn't until a school
nurse noticed the bed bug bites and the
filthy filthiness of the children that
someone intervened
and then on the next page i wanted to
highlight that
vaccines are generally available for
free in new hampshire
for children
and
also if you're interested
the vaccine schedule recommended by the
cdc
for people 18 and under and you can see
that
if someone reaches the age of 16
and i
is
desiring
vaccines
that they have not yet received in their
lives
um due to some kind of neglect on the
part of a parent
um
that would be potentially all of the
vaccines that would have been
recommended by that time
um
the
the vaccines that are only recommended
at age 16 and up
are
the influenza and covid19 vaccines
and i think covid they have it now for
all ages or down to five maybe
so my point is that if you reach the age
of 16
and require more than a flu vaccine it
is through neglect in my opinion and so
i'd like to enable
children
who don't live in a supportive
environment
to
make some limited health care decisions
for themselves if they'd like to and i
think that's the entirety of my
testimony happy to take any questions
thank you
thank you any questions for the
representative
thank you mr chairman
and thank you for allowing me to ask
this question which quite honestly in my
mind i've got like three questions
trying to form it into one
how does a 16 year old understand
understand adverse effects of a vaccine
and what kind of proof goes along with
that
thanks for the question how does a 16
year old understand the results and
consequences of engaging in sex
how do they understand the consequences
of engaging in sex with someone 20 or 30
it is
hard to discuss the issue of consent
it's a complex and very philosophical
discussion
because in my opinion consent should
largely depend on the individual person
and shouldn't be age-based
because you know i have a 15 year old
daughter
she's learning to drive
i'm terrified and i make the
my husband won't let me ride in the car
when she's practicing
because i'll scare her with my noises
um he handles it really well like she
tried to turn he we got to traffic
circle
he told her go left she went left like
real left and he just casually grabbed
the steering wheel and was like i mean
around
so
consent is a very complicated issue that
really ought to depend on the person but
in this situation we're talking about
people who have a desire
to they they've received enough
information they have a desire to make a
decision on their own behalf and they're
living in an environment where they're
not receiving the kind of support that
they need to inform that decision and at
some point there's nothing that you can
do
to improve that situation like in the
if a child
is
severely undersupported in their home
life
it is at some point a disservice to the
child to require that their
uninvolved parents
be the gateway to the decisions that
they need to make for their own health
and safety
i think so i don't know if i answered
your question
yes
i'm male so i i i takes a while for me
to process um
[Laughter]
uh and i'm sorry if i insulted any of
the other males here um but you're
forgiven
that's the way i am um
i guess you did answer my question
because
in in the answer you you basically said
i don't know
um
and i think about my own family
where we do uh and we brought our kids
up through uh understanding how the body
heals itself
and through chiropractic care and
through massage and
mds are invol are definitely involved in
our lives too
but they you know they don't they don't
handle everything um just like the
chiropractor doesn't fix broken arms
i know if my 16 year old son wanted to
go get vaccinated after years of of
understanding how the body heals itself
i would want to have a conversation with
my son or my daughter
and
this bill
it's my understanding
this bill would actually take that right
i'm glad that you have the kind of
relationship with your children where
you're able to impart
that information to them that they
listen
and that they
implement that information in their
lives
and that opportunity that you have to
speak to your children is not taken from
you with this legislation it's your
responsibility as a parent to
establish that kind of communication
with them at a young age to maintain it
to always have their trust and to ensure
that they'll listen to you and do what
you believe is best for their health and
safety
no one can take that right from you as a
parent to be able to communicate with
your children make a good impression and
inform their decisions going forward
that's something that's always been
really important to me with my daughter
from a very young age
i've annoyed her
deeply because she asked me questions
like can i do this can i do that and i
say
you're going to decide and i'm just
going to give you information to inform
your decision and a lot of times i'll
give her both sides of it and i'll make
her decide and it drives her insane and
she says mom just tell me what to do
and she can't deal with it sometimes
because she wants the easy way out and
she doesn't want to critically
think and assess something on her own
but i think it's really important to
instill in her the ability to analyze
and make informed decisions
especially because
she's 15 and a half but she looks like
she's in her 20s and that means that as
she moves through life she's employed
you know she's learning to drive we were
at an event at st anselm's and a girl
walked up here and said did i go to
middle school with you and she said i'm
in middle school at the time and the
girl was a college student at the school
and so i know that with my daughter
looking so much older and doing mature
things like working she's out in the
world she looks like she's another adult
and she needs to be able to
handle herself in a way that protects
her when i can't be there right
and
i think it's really important to
maintain and protect the parents right
and responsibility to communicate well
with their children and impart necessary
knowledge um
but there are definitely children in new
hampshire who have no parents
who who have no parents
available to them to advise them and to
guide them and that's a shame and i
would hate to see that there are
children out there who desperately need
something or another and can't acquire
it because their parents are so
uninvolved
and that's really the intent behind the
legislation it's not to interfere with
the relationship between a parent and a
child but to compensate for the lack of
a relationship
so i don't know if i addressed your
concern but again i'm really glad that
that's
where things are with you and your
children so many parents don't impart
knowledge they just
you know control and dictate and that's
a shame because it puts a child in a
position when they're an adult of not
being able to
um
make informed decisions like we'd hope
and they're just waiting for somebody to
give them instructions you know
representative in such a case where
parents are just plain not involved in
the lives of their children isn't the
proper remedy then for those children to
petition to be emancipated
thanks for the question that's a lot of
work just to get a vaccination if that's
what you want
no it's this bill last bill and a parade
of bills that are all doing the same
thing saying 16 year olds can do what
they darn well want
i don't know if this is an exact session
so i don't know if i should be debating
or just answering questions um
but
i can only speak for the bill that i
filed and i certainly had no knowledge
of any other bills at the time that they
were filed
and i'm not making an argument that 16
year olds should be allowed to do a
plethora of things um in fact the only
argument i'm making is what's in this
bill and i think i closed my testimony
with the statement that there are all
sorts of things that i don't think 16
year olds should be allowed to do
and
with some 16 year olds it may very well
be driving which they're entitled
to begin doing
um and nothing against my daughter who's
possibly watching um
but uh
it's a complicated conversation
and unfortunately this room and the
legislative process isn't set up for
a philosophical conversation we have to
take it one bill at a time before i call
on somebody for the viewing audience the
representative is speaking wonderfully
about her 15 year old daughter
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question um
i'm now chuckling over the 15 year old
daughter compliment and so i'm losing my
train of thought
um
i uh recently
sat in on a discussion about
teenagers being held responsible for
things that they
made crimes they may commit and the fact
that they are not really
totally developed yet
in their thinking that they should not
be held
responsible after a certain point until
after a certain point
um and so then i think back to um
my younger days
and my brother's younger days
and i'm going to talk about
ask you about peer pressure
do you
think that most kids who
try their first cigarettes do it because
their parents said yes or no or because
their friends are doing it
i think my mom's also watching so i'm
but
uh i think going back to
um what representative king brought up
earlier
it's a complex topic
peer pressure is complicated um there's
peer pressure for all sorts of things
and there's a lot of things that i don't
want my daughter doing that are not
illegal for her to do
and we can't leave it to government to
set
the standard for how a teenager should
behave at any given age on all fronts
when she was five we had a very strict
no sharpies and no gums rule or no gum
roll and then she actually stole gum
from her friend's house because i
wouldn't let her have any because i
didn't want her to get it on the walls
or in her bed or in her hair same with
the sharpies i didn't want to after i
cleaned sharpie off of one thing that
shouldn't have had sharpie on it i don't
remember what chemical you need to do
that where i was like we're done with
sharpies and you know how many sharpies
she has in a room now there's a lot
um
there's no law requiring that my
daughter make good friends that are a
good influence on her and i have to
guide her through that um there's
so many things that a parent has to be
concerned about and think through and
manage on behalf of their child if they
want to be as involved for example as
representative king seems to be in the
lives of their children
and those things are things that if the
parent is not involved
the chips will fall where they may
there's no law
dictating what the child should be doing
nothing to ensure that the child will
make healthy and good decisions
in the absence of influence from their
parents
and it
it sucks
that it is
so
that it is so much the responsibility of
parents to guide children
um because all of them deserve a fair
shot but not all of them are born into
good situations
um
and i understand that peer pressure can
be a factor
in so many decisions that a child makes
and
i guess i'm just having trouble seeing
how it matters on this topic more than
any other especially with
things like
your friends are driving why don't you
drive well maybe i suck at it well you
know or your friends are having sex why
don't you have sex guess what they
legally can at 16. is it reasonable
would i agree with it absolutely not
i don't think that teenagers should be
engaging in sex acts i don't think that
they understand what they're doing i
don't think that they understand the
consequences
but they are legally allowed to and they
can be peer pressured into it these are
very big discussions um but i think that
a vaccine
is
not as consequential as some of the
things that we're letting 16 year olds
do by a long shot
i don't know answered
um
you've mentioned that there are a lot of
things that 16 year olds shouldn't be
allowed to do
do you feel maybe we should go back and
correct those things that say
maybe 16 is too young for this maybe
they should have parental
permission before they're allowed to do
these things
um thanks for the question
i think when i saw the movie greece is
when i learned that there's no way
you're going to talk teenagers out of
that
but
i don't think that punishing teenagers
for engaging in sex acts for example and
i know this is way off the topic of the
bill because the bill's about getting
one or two shots here there
um i don't think that uh
punishing teenagers
legally
because there's grounding and there's
you can't have your cell phone and
there's you're done with twitter um but
i don't think that legal punishment
against children is gonna dissuade them
necessarily from sex i don't think
that's necessarily healthy
representative and i think that again
going back to representative king's
example um it's better to have a healthy
open line of communication with your
kids
um
but i think that we should stick to the
bill as the chairman notice
representative folsom follow up okay one
thank you very much one last question um
it feels as if you are throwing um
the parents who are good parents who are
paying attention who are engaged in
their kids lives and all of that and
you're taking away their rights
because of a few the the parents that
are bad apples
is there any way to
not throw the good parents under the bus
thanks for the question
i think that's a that represents a
severe misunderstanding of the bill
if someone has a good open line of
communication with their children the
way that representative king does the
way that i hope i do
um
they don't need to rely on the
government to step in
to prevent their children from doing
things that they would find ill advised
and
i think that that's what is preserved as
i said earlier with this legislation
is a parent's right and duty and
obligation to be a good communicator
with their child be good influence
and
ensure that they're heard when they're
trying to impart important information
which is essentially the only purpose of
parenting is you've made a duplicate of
yourself you need to make it survive in
the wild right you need to pass on the
right information
so if you're going to have children you
need to be able to communicate with them
and it comes with an attendant this time
yeah isn't that good that's really good
no you have an attendant and he's
helping you there we go thank you thank
you amanda if everyone can hear him
i i understand what you're trying to do
and i think this bill uh uh
mentions the teenager and it mentions
the parents but it also involves a third
group of people which are the providers
that give that shot and you did make an
attempt in it to say that they can give
such a vaccination without the consent
of the miners parent or their legal
guardian and i just wonder if this goes
far enough to protect that prescriber
from any legal action that a parent or
someone else may take or
all i'm questioning is
would you have any objection to seeing
it go a little bit further to build that
legal protection if they can't be sued
if they do it thank you
thank you for the question
um i know that in
new hampshire law there are a lot of
situations in which a prescriber has
immunity
um for giving out certain medications
um or other drugs
i
don't know that it would be
advisable to
add such
immunity to this legislation
doctors to be able to take into
consideration
all of the factors
that are uh
part and parcel to the decision that
they're making
i hope that that makes sense and that's
up to the committee it's in your hands
now
but i don't think that that's necessary
and i i hope that that's part of the
provider's decision-making process
thanks representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative bolton for being here and
answering these questions um there a lot
of the the idea when you brought up the
philosophical and personal consent
issues are really intriguing and i think
that's why
to drive to work or to drop out of
school in new hampshire when you're 16
does require parental consent so they're
starting to move towards decision making
in adulthood but they're not quite there
yet so there's that guidance
you're talking about the coven 19
vaccine which is not yet fully approved
it's just in the ua so i know that puts
it down the road but we have a very
coercive environment right now
surrounding this covid vaccine there are
people who are losing their jobs there
are people who are being denied access
to locations there are middle school
trips to washington dc being cancelled
because they don't know the vaccination
status of all of the
students
when we have adults that are having a
hard time standing up to this peer
pressure
how can we expect that six do you think
that 16 year olds have the moral
fortitude and strength to stand up to
their peers when they say amanda unless
you get vaccinated we can't go to the
championship
that's a lot to unpack
um can you walk me through i feel like
there were maybe three questions in
there and i unfortunately i didn't take
notes because i wasn't expecting a lot
do you know that there's consent
required from the parent to drive work
or drop out of school in new hampshire
um i looked up
these laws in preparation for this
hearing and it's my understanding that
only the superintendent's
knowledge of
and consent to dropout is required to
drop out of school in new hampshire and
not parental consent
so then i guess that's the
superintendent
there you require the superintendent
could contact the parents but i haven't
seen anything in new hampshire law
requiring them to so driving and working
and do you agree that it's a very
coercive environment around the vat
covered vaccine right now and people are
having to decide whether to keep their
job or if they don't believe that it's
the right choice sometimes they're
getting fired over this
my daughter works at market basket and
hooks it in the dairy department so if
you want to go bother her
tell her i sent you
she stalks the yogurt and she's never
been asked to be vaccinated she is but
and it was something she wanted she was
really excited to get vaccinated when
she got the little sticker that says
pfizer
is part of the process she put on her
door to her room
but she's never been asked to be
vaccinated
for
school or for work so i guess i'm not
aware of a coercive environment around
i'm sorry
with that i'm glad that your daughter's
not seeing what um
many many people have testified to this
committee and the last one is would you
agree that that teenagers are better
able to stand up to peer pressure than
adults
um i'm not sure that i'd give that much
credit to adults
oh by the way my daughter's also in
sports and she wasn't asked to be
vaccinated for sports
either
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
earlier uh if i understood you correctly
you seem to
imply or actually state
that failure to get recommended or
failure for of a parent
to get their child vaccinated with
recommended vaccines
was tantamount to neglect
and so my question is whether
a decision
to not have a child vaccinated
even
with a vaccine that is recommended
is that a carefully considered decision
by an informed parent or
is that prima facie evidence of
neglect um i think when i said the word
neglect i was talking more from my own
perspective i think that it would be
neglectful
um
i i think really when i say that i find
it neglectful i'm thinking of people
i've known
who were generally neglectful of their
children
and as part of that environment also
their children never went to the doctor
at all they weren't they didn't go to
checkups they didn't go to the dentist
broke an arm
you go to the er you go home that's it
and so i i think i was more thinking of
environments that i found neglectful
that offended me as a parent because i
felt that those children deserve more
um and deserve care and concern about
their health and one of the features in
that environment was
not being vaccinated for any disease
no matter how important
okay
follow-up and the bill applies to
all vaccines that a doctor would find
advisable to give to a child of that age
um so
uh thank you mr chairman so i i think
that clarifies it but i i guess i'll
i'll just ask one further question which
is
um
it sounds like you believe then that a
parent's decision not to have a child
vaccinated
is a legitimate right that sits with the
oh boy
i thought this was the health and human
services committee not the tough
questions careful careful
oh i'm not insulting i'm just kidding
around um
we get that that's a big uh
you guys have a great room by the way
i'm totally jealous and you guys are
really great nature and i like that my
committee's really um stern um not us
it's probably the small room that we're
stuck in um
that's a big discussion um
really um
my personal i think philosophical
perspective on that um because obviously
i might think someone's a jerk for
[Music]
telling their kid
that there's a santa claus because i
remember how much it hurt when i found
out there wasn't and how that affected
my faith
and so many other aspects of my life
right so there's a multitude of things i
could have an opinion about about a
household and about how a child is
reared
i think philosophically
i think that
you should be able to make decisions
for your child
until it can be determined
that
your decisions are harmful to the child
and if they're harmful to the child i
think that there should be intervention
and i think that harm is determined on a
case-by-case basis and i don't know if
that sounds like a it all depends kind
of bs answer and i don't mean it like
that i really think that so many things
depend on the situation the person the
people involved and the impacts of
different decisions in those situations
so that's my philosophical and personal
perspective
but
i think that if
you know
i think that
if
somebody's not
uh home with their child um and their
child's home alone and their child's you
know under 10 i think that if they're
not taking their kid to school i think
that if they're not taking them to the
doctor they don't go to the dentist when
something hurts they only go to the er
if they break something and that's it
and along with that their children are
never vaccinated that's a neglectful
environment overall i think that if it's
a positive environment and there's just
the only thing is that they're choosing
not to vaccinate their child we can have
a discussion
but that's not really what this bill is
aimed at because again if you have a
supportive environment your child's not
going to be running off making decisions
that you disagree with they're listening
to you they're
representative
love
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
would you believe that there is such a
thing as as vaccine injury
and and would you believe that a lot of
parents
um you know when their child is vaccine
vaccine injured
um
it changes their lives dramatically i
know i've got a a 22 year old and i i
understand how how rebellious she was
okay at 16. it's it's fresh in my mind
okay and um
if i said no she should go and do it
anyway okay um you know and uh and
because i have vaccine injured uh nieces
and nephews okay one one from kovac she
hasn't been right for six months
okay she uh gives she got myokaiditis
and she's been suffering ever since uh
i've got a uh my nephew's son uh at the
age of two or three had a vaccine and uh
three hours later he was holding his
head all he did is cry for the next
seven years
okay the my nephew and his wife's lives
were dramatically changed
okay so you're gonna is this bill will
tell me
that
i have no say
okay if
if if my life has a chance of being
dramatically changed
and my child is 16 years old you bet i
want to say in this deal make it a
question
would you would you he didn't say would
you believe you know what would you
believe yeah he had a plan from the
beginning
would you believe the unintended
unintended consequences of this could be
real far-reaching a hypothetical
response question would you believe that
teenage pregnancy can dramatically
change your life
um there's a whole host of decisions
that we already allow 16 year olds to
make
that are life-altering including um
engaging in sex sex with people of any
age um engaging in sex acts without
protection dropping out of school and uh
and as i mentioned equal obtaining and
deploying narcan on an overdosing person
um
life's complicated
one thing that is not part of this bill
that i would support is being able to
open up
vaccine manufacturers to suit
because i think that if you
genuinely believe
that those health effects are the result
of that vaccine you should have your day
in court i think people should have
their day in court for pretty much
anything
but
while you are
surely responsible for
the care of a three-year-old or a
two-year-old
there is a point where we start letting
our children make decisions for
themselves and they should have that
again
what this bill
protects
is your
ability
and responsibility as a parent
to parent your child properly and to
guide them to make the decisions that
you'd like them to make and i know that
teenagers
as a rule have a reputation for
rambunctiousness
but i know that there are exceptions i
think that representative king
described that and i feel like that is
the case in my household i i think that
my daughter is very responsible um
reasonable
uh probably watching and your body
but i mean and she knows it she actually
was recently appointed by the governor
to the legislative youth advisory
council we're going to have to
say i can't brag about her
[Laughter]
you get two sentences to brag on your
daughter daughter pay attention now oh
two sentences
she's she's so smart she's so
responsible um oh that's two sentences
no it's was that a comma okay
she's
um
she's so mature and she's so respectful
that's all
i'm really proud of her but uh
there you go yeah thanks we're starting
to repeat ourselves um all over here so
if there is a different
question
that's okay
anybody with a different question
nope thank you
representative mckay with a different
question
thank you mr chairman
this one is that working
i heard you say we several times but i
haven't heard
that there are two people
involved with some of these decisions i
i take it you have a husband
so you haven't mentioned much about his
um
let's see i don't think i never thought
i'd have to describe my
husband's role he's uh very involved um
he so my daughter does uh she goes to
charter school she goes to velax i don't
know if that's a school that this
committee normally hears about education
committee would
so she does all her school at home
that's why she has the opportunity to
sit and watch this hearing and a servant
you have one sentence to brag on your
husband the representative other bolden
and he does all of her school with her
um he's very involved in her life and
she often goes to him for advice instead
of me but i don't know
what that has to do with the bill
thank you thank you
and thank you representative
say hi to your mom and husband and
daughter for us please thank you you're
welcome
chair recognizes dr gary york from
hopkinton
thank you chairman pearson other members
of the committee
i come here as an unpaid citizen of new
hampshire
defending parents and defending children
i think i'd ask the legislation to
consider this bill as it relates to risk
and benefit
for a 16 year old
in this case we are talking covid
uh
dying for a 16 year old is greater
if they take a vaccine over
the risk of dying for a 16 year old is
greater for someone who's taken the
so-called vaccine
i'd like to just talk a little bit about
some of the
phrases and testimony that we've heard
earlier
and i'll use words that were spoken
desperately needed in the in the
relationship of the vaccine presently
children and
babies infants
up till age 18 don't need to be
jab that is going around and and by the
way just to refer the bill's wording
fda approved
vaccine
we do not have that in this country we
still
have zillions of
unused experimental
vials of vaccine
people have talked about uh peer
pressure
there's a lot of peer pressure in high
school i remember we did some crazy
things
i look at the historically the funds
that came from washington the 22 million
dollars that the executive council
refused to approve
and you know
late at night they were approved
to
[Music]
promote the vaccine
can you imagine
a vaccine
van
driving up to the high school as as they
do in my town their schedule there
and unbeknownst to the parents
well
there's a dare or whatever a decision
from the the team or the gang or the
clique to
let's all go get vaccinated
and they're 16 there they go
unaware of the risks of the vaccine
and yes i think i think a child's brain
a 16 year old child's brain has a long
way to go to be developed fully to make
decisions
last two years of the whole covid
situation
adults have readily signed up for the
vaccine
unaware of the risks unaware of the
vares report
and the dangers of
other
other uh comments that have been made
about
parental decision i defend parental
decisions for children not to get
vaccinated and i think those decisions
need to be honored they're not
neglectful
gathering months ago when we were all
gathered to
[Music]
go against this
money from
washington
and we met a young woman with three
children
who homeschooled her children
they had never had vaccines
they were healthy as horses so to speak
was she neglectful of her children
no does she have the right to have them
so i look at
the
risk-to-benefit ratio if we look if we
could compare this to the previous bill
that was heard i think it was 1409
someone made a clear
argument that there was
very little risk for
mental health services for children who
but the um
there are risks out there for vaccine
children and uh
and young adults
are better off getting
back uh getting
infected with the disease from a naive
standpoint in developing their own
antibodies
so i will just repeat that again the
risk of getting a vaccine the risk of
dying
uh for getting a vaccine is greater than
from getting coveted in the
16 and under age group and be aware that
in the vares report in the state of new
hampshire there is one such case of a 16
would you take any questions from the
the chair now calls upon abigail rogers
and anne-marie mercury
who are not only from the dhhs they also
good morning members in the committee uh
i'm abby rogers i'm the dhhs legislative
liaison and i'm with anne marie mccurry
the nation immunization section chief
we're here to provide some information
related to the bill we're not taking a
position on the bill but we would like
to provide some information on
good morning chairman pearson members of
the committee my name is anne marie
mccary i'm the immunization section
chief for the department of health and
human services division of public health
immunization is considered one of the
most important public health
achievements of the last century safe
and effective immunizations have
prevented millions of illnesses
disabilities and deaths in the united
states despite the success
vaccine preventable diseases such as
measles mumps woven cough and now covet
19 continue to circulate and result in
preventable hospitalizations and death
every year
vaccination coverage is not 100 percent
nor are vaccines 100 percent effective
so outbreaks can occur when an
unvaccinated person becomes infected and
introduces a disease into a community
especially one with low vaccination
rates our best defense against all
infectious diseases is immunization it's
therefore critical to support measures
with which increase access to new
hampshire immunization
because of new hampshire's immunization
school requirements
our teens are well immunized for those
vaccines having school immunization
requirements such as hepatitis b
measles mumps rubella
tetanus diphtheria pertussis and
varicella
our teens however are less protected
against diseases that do not have school
requirements such as hepatitis a
hpv and meningitis this means that at
least 30 percent of new hampshire's
adolescents are not optimally protected
against communicable diseases that can
lead to severe illness disability and
death
although historically new hampshire has
experienced high vaccine rates the
department is concerned about the
disruption of the pandemic
on the receipt of preventative health
care services including routine
immunizations the delay in receiving
immunizations may exacerbate the
potential resurgence of
vaccine-preventable diseases
lowering the age at which an individual
can consent to vaccination services
would increase access to preventive
health services and protect individuals
and others from communicable diseases
the department's goals through
immunization policy are to provide
public health protection while also
appropriately balancing individual
choice
thank you very much i appreciate your
consideration and your opportunity for
me to be here today i'm happy to answer
any questions the chair recognizes dr
sorry representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman not all of us want
to be doctors
um
and thank you for taking the question um
in reference to um the last speaker who
preceded you i'm wondering if you would
agree that
the risk to adolescents from taking the
covet vaccination
various copic vaccinations
the risk of death is greater than
from covid
the disease itself and more specifically
might you have any specific data or
information from new hampshire about
that issue
i think in relationship to hb 1126 we do
want to be clear that this is for those
vaccines that have been
approved by the fda and are and are
licensed for that approval
as such the cova vaccination would not
yet fall under this purview as uh that
is still under emergency use
authorization
i think that for kovid the data is
really still emerging
the information is not clear
it is true that
those that are
infected and are at highest risk do tend
to be in those older age groups however
there are individuals of younger age who
have had
impact from covid19 infection and
disease
is that on
yep um i just wanted to thank you for
allowing me a question thank you for
taking my question i just wanted a
clarification on some of the statistics
that you gave out did you say 27 percent
of new hampshire children have not
received the usual barrage of
vaccinations
so for those immunizations at our school
required our rates are very high
for vaccination rates so we're when
we're looking at hepatitis b mmr tdap
and varicella those rates are
approximately 95 to 98 99
coverage and these statistics do come
from the national institute excuse me
it's a national immunization survey so
this is patient reported survey because
our our immunization registry is so new
we don't actually have actual data from
the state this is coming from parental
survey
so those rates are very high but when we
do look at hepatitis a that rate is 77.8
percent coverage hpv for females is 71.8
percent and meningitis is 91.1 percent
so we do know that there are individuals
that are at risk of communicable
diseases
and when we're looking at the the female
population for hpv for instance um that
rate is approximately 30
um for covid19 although it not
applicable to this uh our vaccination
rate is less than 50 for this age
population okay thank you very much
representative gay
thank you mr chair and thank you
um are you aware that hpv
in many countries has been taken off the
required list and that the
the children
who range in age from
nine to
early twenties
many people have suffered
severe
life
devastating
reactions
and right now is there any kind of test
that you could take before you take the
shot to see if your body would be in
that category that it would
you know react severely
i'm not aware of any such tests i think
that what we do want to do is look at
the data to see
the numbers of cases of cancer that are
being prevented from hpv and compare
that risk benefit
ratio when making those types of
decisions
we want to make sure that this speaks to
it speaks to the bill in that it's
authorizing more people to choose
um
i guess my question was
were you aware of the reactions too
that
that apparently
from
i'm trying to
i don't know and so i'm trying to think
of how to say are you aware of any kind
of fact sheet
on
the hpv or any of the vaccines that
parents or
people over 18 currently
are made aware of the potential
serious ramifications of taking these
like especially the hpv
so the cdc does issue vaccine
information statements that accompany
the vaccination
consent sheets so that people are made
aware of whatever the current data
and
relevant information is when making
any other questions
representative
acton thank you mr chair
um
the basis of of deciding to take a
vaccine
involves informed consent
how does a 16 year old
acquire that informed
consent when we
when what's developed is we
you can't even question
the vaccine you can't we can't discuss
it
results from other countries and so
forth are being censored
so how does a child
receive enough information to make an
informed consent without their parents
thank you for the question
representative acton i think i would i
would add that by the time an adolescent
is usually between the ages and 14 14
and 16 they usually have very pretty
must pretty much um advanced critical
thinking skills they can review
information and make decisions
um they you know should certainly have
as the previous the sponsor the bill
suggested if they have open
communication with their parents they
should be able to have those
conversations about risks and benefits
um certainly if a 16 year old wanted to
get a vaccine
they could access their provider if they
had access to the provider
and you know the the department feels
that kova the coven 19 vaccine for
adolescents often offers high benefit
and low risk
thank you
with that i closed the hearing on house
now just to let us know where we're
heading
i plan on breaking for lunch at 12 15
that will give us an opportunity to
introduce house bill 16
54 and my suspicion is we will continue
after the lunch break
house this opens the hearing on house
bill 1654
fn
relative to termination of pregnancy
statistics and the chair recognizes the
thank you mr chair and members of the
health and human services committee
it's nice to be here i used to work here
and uh good to see you all
i miss the people but i don't miss the
my
bill
hb 1654 fn
to
introduce
the collection and proper
use and dissemination of
pregnancy termination statistics
since
1979 we've pretty much had an open book
on
pregnancy terminations accepting for the
partial birth abortion ban
and a few other
and
peripheral
protections against the unborn and
pre-born
but now
effective on january 1 of course we've
got
hb 625 within the hb2
the 24 week
ban on abortions from 24 weeks forward
so now
we do not have any ability to measure
pregnancy terminations may take place
before or after
and hopefully not after because that
would be a violation of law
so
we really need to have health care
statistics like we already have
in so many areas throughout
the state of new hampshire and
involving many
aspects of
health care
health situations
except pregnancy termination statistics
now
this is not a new attempt um
you know we've had several
runs at this before
hb 158 was a bill that i sponsored last
term
and then there was sb
111 of 2019
and even going back to
471 of 2017 and maybe there's more
but
the process has been helpful
to take objections to those bills and to
make remedy through amendments and then
successive issues of the bills
to the point where i think we've got the
problems ironed out
but that's for you to say
um i have passed out amendment
2022-230238h
and
let me run over those briefly
because they affect the bill in
important ways
the first
paragraph in there
parenthetical d
published report an annual report
commencing with data to be reported as
of january 1st 2023
the delayed date gives the department
time to
set up the necessary protocols
forms and data processes for reporting
and again it restates no data shall be
released to the department that would
have the capacity to personally identify
either
the health care provider who performed
an induced termination of pregnancy or
the patient on whom it was performed
except
pursuant a search warrant issued under
rsa 595 a
and so forth
now we didn't have that in prior bills
but since we do have the 24-week
ban on abortions
now there is that possibility that there
might be a violation
and if there's a violation in the
process of investigation and law
we we need to make sure that
certain information might be available
going on further
recommending with amending rsa 126 colon
with the
paragraph that follows
and
that is pretty much a housekeeping thing
we heretofore referred to the new
hampshire health wisdom system
which has
a great deal of helpful information and
about all kinds of health care
situations
but that is being morphed into um the
health and human services data portal if
you go on and you google wisdom
it'll bring you into a new face on
screen
which is identified as the health and
human services data portal so these
things changed so we wanted to make sure
that we weren't
hemmed into
the next paragraph data may be person
that may personally identify either the
health care provider who performed an
induced termination of pregnancy
or the patient on whom it was performed
shall be exempt from disclosure
requirements of rsa 91a
of course we don't want
any of that information
out on a out in the public
leaking out to violate the privacy of
the provider or
the patient
so that's an important component
to make sure 91a isn't used as a
leverage to procure this sensitive
information
and then the last paragraph on the
any data collected pursuant rsa 126
colon 25 that may personally identify
either the health care provider who
performed an induced termination of
pregnancy
or the patient on whom it was performed
this exemption shall not include
non-identifying information required to
be disclosed under rsa 126 colon 25.
so um only the collection dissemination
of authorized
data with all of the restrictions we've
built into
the bill
all the restrictions that are already in
the body of law in 126
and the restrictions that the federal
people have in hipaa
we're not interested
in individuals
knowing individuals who may have had an
abortion
or and the providers to those
we want the data
our society runs on data and information
that's how we grow and improve
here we have a big blind spot without
any termination of pregnancy statistics
numbers
so how can we understand
a plan
make remedy for
improve our situation of health if we
have a big gap and void
and and i would say that this bill will
help close that gap
and it will put this element of data and
information into the already existing
body of law
in rsa 6 126
title 10.
and there's a lot of precautions
guards
and even penalties for violation
of uh
collection or dissemination
and even failure to report
properly
data for the system
so
we've attempted to cover all of the
bases in here taking from the prior
bills
the good stuff and adding
the the information and the components
that you all had mentioned on previous
and i'm going to restate that we have no
interest in knowing the individuals
involved
in the termination of pregnancy
we want the data
and
the whole country
utilizes data we're one of only three
states that has not reported to the cdc
maryland california and new hampshire
and this bill will enable that
black spot to be
see the light of day with regard to the
statistics and join the other
states that have already been reporting
um i'm going to
close with that and
be willing to answer questions as they
are
i have one representative and thank you
for testifying today um would you
believe that i faced the same thing as
chairman of two
deaf and hard of hearing committees in
this state that new hampshire for some
reason known only to god is data phobic
yes mr chair i would believe that thank
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative stapleton for taking my
this is a um these bills have one been
ones that have puzzled me um
since i first started hearing them and i
i have to agree that i don't understand
why this care procedure is treated so
differently than others
um that being said i have a couple of
questions about your bill
one is does the does the bill actually
say what data is to be collected and
aggregated or is that is that
specifically in an rsa that
the bill refers to
this bill does bring forward from prior
attempts the type of data
which is to be collected and it'll be on
in
starting at line
four
that gives you the detail that
of determination by month and year
method of termination
and there's four
general categories that are covered in
that
follow up
i apologize i was just looking at the
amendment
thank you
second question is
it seems like there's a there's a
question of whether the data should be
aggregated
by the department of health and human
services
or whether it should be aggrava ag
aggravated um this is kind of
aggravating um aggregated
prior to being sent from the the medical
providers who
perform abortions
and
some
it would be an inadequate to have the
providers themselves aggregate the data
before it gets sent to health and human
services
thank you for your question um i'm
looking at
page one of the bill
under
section 1
sub
paragraph a
aggregate summary means a compilation of
the information received
by the department of health and human
services on induced terminations of
pregnancy
so by the definition
that's putting that responsibility
upon the health and human services
department
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative stapleton to take my
question
would you believe
in the state of new hampshire we have a
long history of privacy
and we have actually in our constitution
i think it's an article two
the bill of rights specifically talks
about an individual right to live free
from governmental intrusion and private
or personal information natural and
central
and that's inherent
and
when i look at this bill
i think it's a violation of the
constitution because we're asking for
people to provide information that's
private and
if we're really going to abide by the
constitution of privacy
should we not at that point in time
respect that and if a patient wants to
have it submitted like we do with other
things maybe the patient should have the
right to opt out
and therefore we can then bring it to
the patient so the patient has that
right to opt out
and number two
when you deal with
privacy
there's another bill before us i think
it's
dealing with the department health and
human services about security and
privacy
and trying to beep up our system from
being hacked
so people have data in the system that
we can protect their
privacy
not just the security but the privacy of
the data
so would you believe that i think in
your opinion
how this does not violate the
constitution and does it subject the
patient to the potential for getting
hacked into a database
well thank you for your question
representative
and
i do believe that uh privacy is a very
important and an essential component of
our system
that's why we spent a great deal of time
over three attempts at this bill
to make sure data in the aggregate and
no identifying data would be
attended to
the collection of the
of the statistics and the dissemination
of them in the
health care portal
or
for the department in other areas
and so if you read through the bill they
talk about the creation of confidential
codes
that
represent
but not identify the patients and the
providers
except by
location of
city
and county and so forth except
if there's uh a location that's
underneath 20 000
then
what would you say diluted so that there
wouldn't be
an identification by people who could
maybe somehow
think that they they could identify or
assume to identify some people
i don't believe that it's a violation
of our constitutional rights either
state or federal
to collect this data
we collect data
all over on different types of diseases
and it's important for us to be able to
know
what we're going to do about diseases
that we collect data on and give us
indications where we have problems
not unlike the the p5s problem that we
have in the state
and we continue to collect data because
that's going to be an expanding
awareness
we need an expanding awareness on
something that's been voided
out of our health care statistics and
that is
that is pregnancy termination
and
you know not only from decided or
willful abortion but for
health reasons and surgical for
miscarriages and toxic pregnancies and
so on and so forth
we have a right of privacy
under our constitution
but that privacy does not
trump the other articles of our
law under the constitution and it
doesn't trump the right of the state to
be able to provide
security safety
health care oversight whatever you will
and to do this we protect the right of
the privacy of the individuals by
keeping them out of the data out of
dissemination
but yet meet our mission and goal to
understand
uh what our health situation is in so
many areas so that we could do the best
we can
to remedy shortfalls and to progress in
better health care
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative taking my question
if we're looking for the
data the aggregation of the data which
is basically we call patient d
identified
why not have the data that's going to be
submitted by the provider go into the
department health and services
patient d identifies in other words the
provider is not providing any patient
names and
numbers and so forth so you can still
collect the data without submitting
anybody's personal information with that
data
could that possibly be done so basically
what's going into the department is in
fact de-identified before it gets to the
department
so at that point in time it's really not
violating our privacy because it's been
de-identified we don't have to worry
about something hacking into the system
because it's been de-identified but we
still at the end of the day you get
aggregated data
thank you for your your question um
the bill
enables the uh identif
enables a code coding system
um for the
provider as well as the patient
confident and these are confidential
numbers
the
the provider will provide the data on
that basis
and
that data comes to the health and human
services department and is going to be
held in confidentiality according to the
law under 126 title 10.
and we've already had several years
of
operation of 126 and
i don't know of any data breaches
or hacking attempts that has
purloined any information
of any type of healthcare situation from
the database now maybe health and human
services can speak better to that
question if they've had a breach
and how they've had a breach
and what was the extent of that
but remember
126 is a well-established body of law
relative to
health
care and health statistics
and there are penalties for
uh the breach
of dissemination of this information
it's a class b felony
and
for the provider to misstep
and falsely report or fail or to report
under the protocols which will be
established by health and human services
that under 126 colon 29 that brings a
fine of a hundred dollars a day
for every day of non-compliance
so
between
in addition to the law we have the
experience and the professionalism of
health and human services department
that has been working on these systems
for years
and i think they can better testify that
i don't believe they've had
significant
breaches if any at all but they have to
testify to that
thank you mr chairman
and welcome back and thank you for
i'm still trying to follow up on the use
of a patient's confidential
identification code or number
i i think really i'm trying to follow up
on representative shapiro's question
about
aggregating at the provider level versus
aggregating at the department level
and so if you are aggregating at the
provider level they're going to
give a report that says cheshire county
and the number
of cases
i
i can't understand why
the aggregation would be done at the
department level which provides one more
opportunity
for an individual's number to be
worked backwards into a personal
identity
rather than having
the information be aggregated
at the local level
and given that we are a state
where
there are an awful lot of real small
towns and i appreciate that the bill
provides that you will only report by
county if you're above
if
if your town is below 20 000 in
population
sorry i wonder
about the trade-off
between privacy which we're all
concerned about and protecting the
individual's identity
and
getting to the point where the data
isn't particularly useful
i i certainly would prefer to see
county-wide reporting but
um
i have the two questions one being the
aggregation at
the facility level rather than at the
department level and the other is
just
the trade-off between trying to balance
the privacy with the usefulness of the
statistics
thank you for your question um
the short answer would be for
the department
is going to administer
the
data
computer program if you will
and the forms to be used during the
process
and so that's the hub of the wheel if
you have every one of the spokes on the
wheel
aggregating or furnishing data
at their own
choice of importance or evaluation of
importance then
we're not going to get good data we have
to do this in an organized fashion and
the department would be the base
to create and
facilitate the system as well as to
provide the forms and the questions that
are going to be asked on there and they
also
will be the ones in charge of keeping
secure the the codes that are utilized
for this reporting
um
i don't see
where you you can secure or you can
assure
the quality of data by letting the
spokes on that wheel determine to what
extent they're going to combine
aggregate
report
the data and i think it has to be a
highly disciplined system so that we a
protect the privacy of the individual by
the codification
and b get the quality of data that will
be useful
uh and important to us
i i don't know if that answers your
representative leon
thank you mr chairman um as our
epidemiologist isn't here today could i
make a statement on the data as an
analyst
sure um
no no no no you can't okay that we had
had the other people before so were you
okay thank you then i'll proceed to my
questions i just know we've done that
with other people as well in the past
um
when we look at this information and the
importance of having the information
available to the department of health
and human services so that they can
actually make use of this important data
i do know that it makes sense to
have the
greatest granularity that does not
compromise patient safety so that the
department would be able to run
meaningful analyses upon this
information
um i think that this information could
really help us with health equity and
disparity if we do find that vulnerable
populations are going to uh are seeing
disproportionate use of this service and
i'm curious about whether race and
ethnicity
income and parity meaning the number of
previous births or pregnancies were left
out to protect privacy or if those are
something that could let us see if
vulnerable populations are
utilizing the service more than others
in our community
thank you for that interesting question
i don't see a breakout for
race
or other criteria
and i think it focuses on
the physical aspects of why and how
abortions are taking place
as well as other pregnancy terminations
but that's an interesting
question and maybe
at some point that department might find
that useful and bring us a request for a
bill to provide additional aspects
but this one does not have that in-depth
breakout
the church disappointed that there was
no one
lined up
to answer all the
hard technical questions of privacy and
so on however
our friends at dhhs provided me with the
numbers of people i have calls out to
them i will continue because they can
answer the
vital records questions and safety and
all of these issues that we have before
us i hope to get them here for the
continuation of this hearing after lunch
but
we'll see so we will now
break for lunch and resume at one
o'clock
house bill 1654
and
i'm wondering if representative merchant
would address
uh representative stapleton with some of
the questions we're trying to come to
to yes here and i think we're on the way
but for the sake of everybody would you
raise your questions and and do a little
bit of dialogue back and forth i realize
uh this isn't the exact session but we
have the sponsor with the answers here
mr chairman if i may um given the time
and the hour of the day
could i possibly have a conversation
with representative
stapleton and then possibly come back to
an exact session with some solutions to
the questions that certainly could be
possible but the hour of the day
question is house bill 1180 for those of
you here for it will be postponed until
february 22nd i'll call that in
to being and then recess it um
so we do have some time before our next
hearing
if you wish if you wish i i
thank you that
mr chairman but i think the conversation
like to have with
representative stapleton is a very
detailed very lengthy conversation and i
think the better place for us is to have
it offline and further i would encourage
if you want to mr chairman is to appoint
a couple of other people with us to have
an ad hoc group and talk about the issue
in more detail and come back with
something that's meaningful to the
committee
uh yeah absolutely we can do that um
if the representative uh would wish to
continue from where we left off
uh yes thank you mr chair and members of
the committee uh for the record walt
stapleton uh claremont ward 3 sullivan
county district 5
representing
my bill hb 1654 fn
representative knurk
thank you very much and pleasure to have
you back again i did have a question
though um
earlier you made a comment about
you kind of made some comparisons to
other diseases and to pfas into
gathering data we really need to address
problems
and since this actually is not a disease
nor an environmental toxin but it's an
elective surgical procedure
with a low risk profile or an electric
medical procedure since medical is
included i'm curious what the
perceived problem is that you
think we need this data in order to
address
thank you for the question
when they had
the wisdom
graphic system up and alive and working
very well
last year
before they started making changes and
morphing it into the new hampshire
health data portal
you could go in there and search any
number of
health subjects
and get various aspects almost like
custom build
what information you could derive i
haven't seen that in the new hampshire
data portal at this point yet maybe
that's coming
so i looked at pregnancy
and there are there was a whole
bunch of nice data relative to
pregnancies by age
by difficulties and
any number of things but it was missing
the aspect of termination of pregnancy
and so
one of the things this bill would do is
to insert that aspect of
information
into
that non-identifiable aggregated data
so that we could understand how many for
instance how many per uh how many
terminations are occurring in the state
and of the four or five categories
mentioned in the bill
follow-up yes well that tells us the
data but what is the perceived problem
for which we need to gather this data
because you talked about
problems
um
which
and even on the other things i mean
we talked about problems what is the
perceived problem for which we have to
gather the data as to the numbers
thank you for the question that is
was my perception
of the use of that word
and
i personally believe that abortion
is a problem
we're taking the life
of a potential citizen
of a human being
and abortion occurs at any
weeks
in during the pregnancy except now
not on or after the 24th week so we
still want the data
to know how many are done in the state
is an important thing
um and under what procedures
that they are being done
and
there may be a breakdown of other
information that can come out of looking
at those counts against the procedure
specified in the bill
and
you know it comes under health care and
health statistics in 126 so
to me it's a shoe-fit
shoe that fits
maybe not necessarily a problem for many
people
of perception
mine maybe but um
problem or not a problem we should know
if we have a problem or not a problem
and how many of these terminations and
how they're happening in the state
may i be allowed another follow-up
another follow-up but generally a
problem is because you perceive there's
something that needs to be addressed to
be changed so for example we might
let's take something else that's
elective and this is really not a good
analogy but
i mean just any other kind of elective
procedure we wouldn't view it as a
oh oh i'm sorry
am i oh
yes i'm sorry i did not realize i'm not
usually i was hearing you i'm okay okay
well yeah basically usually we are
speaking about a problem gathering data
so that we can make an intervention to
alter it so
for example if we have a high rate of
maternal mortality we might want to find
out what the factors are so we can
address those
um so what is the perceived problem here
when it's an elective
procedure
either medical or surgical
of an individual
what is the perceived problem
we're not going to this bill is not
going to measure
the follow-on after a termination of
pregnancy
there's no provision for that intrusive
look into
problems that occur during the abortion
where
a woman's life and health is at risk
because of the abortion
um
now maybe down the road in the future
that might be something but not in this
bill
the problem
and we probably shouldn't use the word
problem because it's a matter of law
we have roe v wade and planned
parenthood versus casey and doe versus
bolton
that's where the determination is if
they're going to be any remedies if that
law changes
so
we're not we're not going to use this
data to address any particular aspect of
the procedures involved in termination
of pregnancy
but if we see a problem
that
or or indication from the data that
there is
a large number of pregnancy terminations
in one particular procedure or another
that may be beneficial to the medical
community to
address modify um examine evaluate
that's the purpose of data
we're not trying to pin the
tail on the donkey here we don't want to
know who the individuals are
we don't even want to know who the
providers are in the public information
but we want to know the extent of this
practice
because
since 1973
it's estimated there have been 62
million abortions in the united states
now
that comes from a combination of sources
including the guttmacher institute which
is the prime research arm of planned
parenthood where it was they may have
split now
that's a lot of people that's like
one-third of our population total we got
340 million people
now i would classify that as a problem
these are future citizens this is a loss
of resource
this is a want and waste
we want to know to what extent new
hampshire may be participating
in that
and know whether we're
about like the same as other states more
or less relative to our population
of what 1.34 million people
representative leon has a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
i
was looking to see what the cdc uses it
for and i appreciate that you're
probably more interested in the
calculated the national legal induced
abortion case fatality rate but you are
aware are you aware that three other
things they do are to evaluate the
success of programs aimed at promoting
equitable access to patient-centered
quality contraceptive services in the
u.s to calculate pregnancy rates rates
based on the number of pregnancies
ending in abortion along with the
collected birth data and to monitor
changes in clinical practice
in relation to this are you aware that
the cdc uses it that way
that's interesting that's an interesting
and i can see the applicability for that
because our population replacement rate
is somewhere
is it you know 9 4 or 1.10 or something
like that
and it should be
like two
because it takes two people to make a
pregnancy
and
we're
for a society to grow and flourish it
needs to replace at least those two
people and if we're
you know 0.94 or 1.10 or whatever the
figure is now
we're not making it
except maybe by illegal immigration
um but that's another subject we're not
going to go there but
i see from your question that that what
we want to do fits in to the scope of
the overall development of knowledge
to help us understand where we go as a
population and as a culture
i'm breaking what i just said about
holding this off but i wanted to make a
comment
no
kyle asked a question
thank you
would you believe okay
go back to i mentioned before we have a
probably in a lot of ways leading the
country because one of the things i'm
seeing now is when i go on to websites
is i have the option with the cookies i
can choose what information i want to
share
i have that option now
so therefore
when i go back to this basic bill
would you be willing to consider an opt
out we talked about this before this is
a
patient's information it doesn't belong
in the government's hand unless the
patient consents to it that's kind of
the reason why we have a constitution
here
article 4 in the bill of rights
would you be willing to allow the
patient to opt out sharing that data
because it really is their data not the
governments
thank you for your question and i
appreciate
your emphasis on privacy and i concur
with its uh valued importance in our
culture and in our law
you're going to create undue confusion
and
impair the
value of the record by letting people
opt out
we're going to protect privacy because
we're not interested in the identity of
either the patient or the provider and
we're structuring
within the bill those protections and
we've already developed those
protections in
and if you want if you don't want to
have well the term was dirty data the
last go around of hearings that we had
if you'd like the data to be
good data
um useful data
then
opt out is is not necessary
or is it
advisable in order to get the
statistics that we ultimately want and
that's all we want is the numbers the
statistics
representative would you say there's a
difference
between an opt-in or opt-out question
when it has to do with somebody's name
versus opt-in opt-out
thank you for the question that's
the provider is the one that keeps the
detail
and so
can they opt out to expunge their record
from
well
i don't know you see doctors and
facilities are supposed to keep records
about the procedures they conduct and
the patients that they treat
now
we're not going to upload that
information to the system
the
the provider
makes the code
all of the patient data doesn't get
uploaded
from the provider's files
the code against the four or five
termination of predicate categories
is the only thing that the department is
going to get
if you want to know who the patient is
then you've got to go to the provider
and the systems that have been developed
by the state of new hampshire and other
states protecting data of all kinds
privacy data according to hipaa and
state regulations
has been pretty successful
and you know that you can't just walk in
a hospital and get data on anybody
because there's a great deal of concern
the provider information
that
the provider takes
stays in the files of of the provider
now
if there's a problem with a leakage
or a dissemination
it's not the state that's going to be
able to do that it's the provider that's
going to be vulnerable to that if he
fails to have safeguards
for protecting that information
we're not interested in getting that
information all of that detail uploaded
because then there'll be no control over
it and what if it changes what are you
going to do updates to all that
information
thank you again mr chair and thank you
again for taking my question this is a
follow-up to i think both represent to
representative leon's uh comment and
then something you said as well
if what we're doing if the purpose
behind this is to
both look at
the loss of potential citizens and also
to
figure out if there are areas or
populations that are underserved or
that are receiving
less
effective care than others
shouldn't don't you agree that we should
be also collecting miscarriage
statistics as well as abortion
statistics so we can see
uh which also reflect on levels of care
and
failure of contraception
well no that wouldn't be a failure of
contraception but levels of care
available
among other things and so for
epidemiological purposes would we
wouldn't it be better if we were
collecting both
thank you for that interesting question
that adds some dynamic to
the subject of data
the short answer is no because this bill
doesn't intend to address that but
you know in the into the future
um we might find a need for that and if
so then a bill has to come forward to
authorize that
the scope of this bill is narrow
to find out the reasons
or the procedures
for pregnancy termination and how many
there are
it is a rather narrow focus admitted
but
um
we wanted to be able to comply with
data use
as
reporting to the cdc
and also fill the gap in our data
in the
health care portal
under the category of pregnancies
the chair has a question
since
this data is collected in all but three
states
there's a lot of red states and there's
a lot of blue states
do you know why they collect such data
because that's what we're asking right
now why do we need this well 47 states
seem to have a reason for that do you
well thank you mr chair for the question
we believe that
pregnant
pregnancy termination is an important
subject and aspect of
health care and health condition in the
united states
and since we've had
roe v wade in
1973 that opened the door to the
question of how many abortions are going
to be taking place
under the new law then
and as we change the law as we have in
dough vs bolton and planned parenthood
versus casey and a number of other
supreme court decisions
we want to know to what extent when the
states want to know to what extent
you know are we increasing or decreasing
what where is that
human resource going how is it being
disposed
and as i said before with 62 million
abortions
estimated since 1973 this is a large
impact on our culture our society our
humanity
and and even our national tradition so
for all of these reasons and
also for what the medical community can
gain out of information like this i
think it's vitally important
to have this component and states have
recognized that and i'm hoping new
hampshire through this bill
can be
one of those reporters
thank you chairman my questions were
covered by representative weber
is actually two questions but
so if i'm allowed the liberty to ask one
and follow for the other
um regards to
my medical record it's my medical record
it belongs to me not the provider
they're the holder of it but it belongs
to me personally has been decided by the
courts many times
in regards to the data gets released by
the provider i have to sign a release
form
no data goes to a billing company no
data goes to anyone else unless they're
involved with my care
so therefore i give them permission
i sit down and sign a release form
i either opt in or opt out
to that data being shared with anyone
else including the building department
now if i want to pay cash
i can opt out of sending the information
to the billing company but i have that
option i have that choice we're taking
this away
would you believe that that's my intent
here is that we're trying to protect the
patient's privacy and allowing them to
have control over that data
including what's in the medical record
would you believe that thank you for the
question
we have laws on the books
to protect
patient data and
your right to have and hold that data
and if you're going to transfer you can
get a copy of it to physicians so on and
so forth
we're not talking about the same thing
here we're talking about account
we're not talking about the detail with
your name on it with your medical
condition or conditions with the
treatments you've had the physicians
you've seen
none of that
is going to be uploaded into the system
which is the reason for
the patient confidential number
going against a procedure
there there is no disclosure in that
process
and and
if you ask the department um
who is that number
you've got to go back to the provider
and the provider is responsible
and under due process is supposed to be
protecting this information and enabling
you to get it
department is not going to be handling
that request or or that control
your provider is going to be work taken
and condensing and if you will probably
you could even use the term aggregating
all of that into a number
on one procedure two procedure three or
four
and
the number goes into the department for
the count for the statistics
statistics we're not looking for the
detail we're looking for the statistics
follow up
thank you for that
just as a
aside
would you believe when i work at the
medical center we're
very concerned about patient data
and we had third parties involved with
us would you believe that we went to
great extents
a great extent to be sure that any
identifiable information including the
prescription number
which we think would be central and so
forth but it'd be traced back to the
patient so any kind of a number that
goes back to a patient's chart or back
to any kind of way can be traced back to
that patient
so when you start we all talk about the
code a code links back to a patient
that's patient identifiable information
although we have a disagreement on this
and number two when you talk about the
issue of dirty data this only talks
about
pregnancies that's terminated medically
it doesn't talk about a chemical
termination
so also we're not including tremendo i'm
not advocating for this but if we have
terminal termination through a chemical
means
that data is not going to be in this
data stream
so right then and there we're going to
have dirty data because we're not
capturing all the terminations we're
only capturing a subset of the total
so i would love to have a conversation
with representative stapleton and get
into more of this detail
because i think that's where the
conversation probably has to go
well thank you for the the question
uh chemical
abortions
should be attended by a physician
prescribed by a physician
and
now maybe the law is going to change on
that we've already talked uh you know
telemed
of prescriptions and abortions and so
forth
well
that's not the problem of data
statistics that's a problem of on the
ground
control
of of health care
yeah you've got
a number of third parties as you say
that contribute to health care and
procedures
medicine
and
you know insurance
um
physical therapies any number of things
there's a large
wheel of medical practice that goes into
health care
we're not interested we're not on the
ground level of that detail
boil it down
confidential number non-identifying and
put that number against a
pregnancy termination
practice our procedure
that's it if
if you if even if we added the 595
section for in a case of a warrant and
the reason we did that is because
since 1979 we've had little or no
restrictions or laws on the books
against abortion but now we've got the
24 week plus
abortion ban
and everybody you know 90 of population
is going to obey the law and they're
going to be good citizens but you're
always going to have
the miscreants that are going to
compromise or
downright
invalidate or
violate the law
so we have to have a penalty
and when you have a penalty and you have
to have a charge under our system to
prove it in court
there are such things as search warrants
and investigations and the process of
getting that information under your
medical record
doesn't come from the department because
they haven't got it
you go to the provider with a court
a search warrant that's authorized by a
court of law to address an indictment or
an investigation
we're not this is data over here this is
statistics
count only you're talking about what's
over here for the application the ground
floor application of medical practice
and the confidentiality of records we're
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
you just basically brought up the issue
that i had
the information that's being held by the
department is all i'm impressed with the
steps you've taken
to protect the anonymity of both the
provider and the patient
however in the case that you said where
a case situation arose where court
issues a search warrant
who would that search warrant go to
would it go
to the department you said it would have
to be delivered
to the provider but how does
how do they find out who the provider is
unless that information
is that a quirk in it that they could
identify the
provider by contacting you and then
that's a backdoor way of then getting to
who the patient is is
is that it going to be a problem
thank you for the question uh no it's
not
let's use a hypothetical if a search
warrant
and a sheriff appears at the department
of health and human services
it's going to have a name on it it's
going to have
a provider
maybe
if the search warrant pertains to a
violation by a provider
i can't see how that would have a
patient name on it
what violation is the patient
you know it doesn't make sense so
the first thing that
the department is going to have to say
is that we don't have the information
you want
you have to go back to the provider
because we're not uploading all of this
patient data
and uh the including the detail
of how the procedure that was
statistically marked with a number
was performed
or what the gestational age of the
patient
or the patient's fetus was
he doesn't the department's not going to
have any of that information
so
the
warrant really has to defer to the
provider who continues to have all of
that information
but
follow up
follow him thank you
isn't it also possible that
possibly the search warrant is against
the
patient
who had the abortion after the 24-week
threshold
and
but the only way to get to that would be
if they somehow identified the provider
who gave it
but it seems to me that
how do you handle a search warrant you
can't refuse
to cooperate
they just do not have any information
that they could get back to the
provider and who
you seem to indicate that they could get
to the provider by contacting you
but not to the patient but sometimes
they're possibly looking for the patient
is and i think the big concern everybody
has if if the state is going to collect
this data and i've done something that i
find personally
not something i am proud of
or happy to have done
i don't want that information to ever be
made public is this a possible backdoor
way that it could come in
and they could get that information
no and here's why um
let's go on that assumption that uh the
search warrant relates to the patient
and
the law
here isn't written to
[Music]
file against the patient but the
provider the provider is responsible for
establishing that gestational age
under the 24-week ban
and of course the patient has a
responsibility to answer questions
honestly and in the interview process
and then of course you have the other
tools um and kind of
tools to make the determinations to
so that i i don't foresee a problem
against the um
the patient as a matter of fact i think
i recall in some sectional law that uh
prosecuted
in that particular instance
so
the the search warrant comes in into the
department of health and human services
and they got a patient number
now remember the provider creates the
patient number
the department doesn't create the
patient number and they don't get an
uploaded data to identify that
so they have to say
to the officer you have to go to the
provider he can identify whether or not
this patient who you've just named
and we don't have that information here
and so you have to go to the provider
with with your warrant
representative i can understand how
gosh the colors i think it's red
conservative states
might not fret this so much
but
since it's 47 states that have data
isn't it interesting do you think
that
blue states liberal states quote unquote
are already doing this kind of thing in
some form or another they've jumped
these hurdles that we're asking we're
not the trailblazers here do you find
that interesting that
blue states do this too
yes mr chairman i i think that does
testify to the
general nature
and the recognization of the value of
having
health care statistics including this
particular one thank you representative
folsom
thank you chairman thank you
representative stapleton
i'd like to just speak to the process of
am i not speaking close to i'm sorry
i'm gonna
run through a process and you can tell
me if this is true or not if this how it
falls out is it true that is it true
that
thank you
um
if a warrant
if a warrant is issued
that there has to be a case
a criminal case
filed
for a warrant to be issued
and if that's the case
or
or civil case but
you know but there is a case that's been
filed
that case only gets
filed against the provider
if someone believes they have
overstepped the bounds and gone past the
24 weeks
so that initial warrant they already
know who the provider is because someone
has come to them and said
this provider we're
you know almost positive 100 sure they
went past the 24 weeks
and then
the warrants are are issued to obtain
actual factual information
which could either
prove the case true or it could provide
evidence that it wasn't true and
actually
give the provider
a defensive out
thank you for the question what you've
provided is the administration of
the legal process investigation and
court and
bringing charges
this bill has nothing to do with that
the only reason i mention 595 is because
in the case that information was needed
for this prosecution or this
investigation
authorized by a court under a search
warrant
that
the possibility is there
to obtain
information that might be available it's
not going to be available by the
department but it will be available
from the provider
in the detail that you've just described
in the case that you've just
provided an example about
any other questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you so much
mr chair yes
i have
extended travel here
coming up and the next day
and um it was travel that was arranged
quite some time ago
and so
there would be a conflict with uh having
further discussions in executive session
i would be available by
email
to be able to respond to questions but
not a physical presence to be
here for a dialogue or discussions or
even the exec
session because i understand you were
going to execute this bill sometime
i think so the 8th of february maybe
it's an early bill so yes we are yeah
and i'm not going to be back until the
8th well
i understand that a conversation with
representative merchant he was
suggesting on some of the questions we
had discussed before we resumed the
hearing we would like to put together a
group of
three or four or five people to
go into depth representative merchant
thank you mr chairman also thank you
griffin
i do have like a lot of us a zoom
account and if you're traveling in some
place that you can get to a computer
maybe one of the things we can do to try
to accommodate your schedule and
everyone else's schedule is to set up a
possible before i forget are there a
couple of people on either side who
might like to join in with
representative merchant and the primary
sponsor
um representative leon
and
king and a couple folks on your side
representative
woods
i think that's pretty good does that
sound fair good
okay that'll be the group that'll be the
group that will work on this more fully
may i make one more point
i would like to see
some testimony or some input from
department of health and human services
especially from
the folks that administer
the new hampshire vital record
information network
because on my bill right the procedure
and the protocols are going to hearken
underneath that particular aspect of the
department i'm going to ask you to talk
with john williams to get those names
and
abby rogers those names and contact
information that will give you exactly
and representative merchant if you would
had this this little group up would you
mind
no no
you wouldn't mind no i or no you don't
want to yes i will no i don't mind
okay good thank you
okay thank you representative now thank
you the chair calls frank and pardon me
you oppose the bill you have written
testimony there's almost enough copies
to go around oh i have extra if there's
not enough okay because there's 21 of us
mr chairman members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify today my name is frank knack
from the policy director with the aclu
of new hampshire and we are here in
so as you know a lot of our testimony
and a lot of the stuff you'll read on
our fact sheet has already been covered
so i'll try and um uh not uh repeat what
has already been said just to point out
that
the state's division of vital records i
think to back up
one of the early points brought up in
this debate
is you know what what we were talking
about here in terms of collecting data
around and i just want to make clear on
the record that we were talking about a
medical procedure that we're going to be
collecting data around and despite that
fact the uh
the state's division of vital records
collects information around birth
marriage civil unions divorce civil
union dissolution and birth certificates
it collects nothing around a medical
procedure and so i think it's important
to recognize that what we're doing here
is collecting information singling out
one type of medical procedure
constitutionally protected medical
procedure for data collection and we do
so despite the fact that we've talked
about aggregate versus individualized
the way that this bill is drafted you're
collecting individualized data the forms
require individualized data
and i just did a quick google search
last year alone in the united states 40
over 40 million patient records were
subjected to a hack or or a breach data
breach and that is just in 2021 alone
and you'll note in my fact sheet um i
cite to a
page by the center for strategic
international studies uh kind of the the
international relations think tank in dc
and the point of doing that is they
actually looked at data breaches at a
nation-state level so countries that
have
extremely sophisticated cybersecurity
measures in place and the list goes on
and on and on about nation states and
major defense contractors whose data was
breached
and so i think it's important to
recognize that we were talking about
collecting individualized records
at the provider level that will then be
going to
the aggregate to the state but that
individualized records are still there
with the patient number compared with
with the with the procedure itself and
so all that is subjected and didn't
think back to 40 million records alone
last year
compromised
i think it's also important to point out
that which hasn't been discussed thus
far today is the cost of what we're
talking about here you know
there are approximately 100 000 people
in our state who are living below the
poverty line at or below the poverty
line and we're talking about spending
almost half a million dollars over the
next three fiscal years
implementing a data collection portal
that has from what we can tell from the
debate thus far
not a valid purpose because we are again
singling out a single medical procedure
for a data collection in a portal that
is only collecting the non-medical
procedure data
so the rest of my testimony i think has
already been covered
in detail so i'll leave it there thank
you chair has a question am i to
infer correctly
that therefore
the aclu would stand four square firm
solid
with those citizens who do not want
their vaccine information sent anywhere
we are talking about a distinction
between individualized and aggregate
data collection our concern is that
under this bill it would be
individualized out of collection we have
no con we think data collection is
extremely important you know there's
some great legislation before this
legislated by this year around traffic
stops and race disparity that we think
is extremely important
our concern is not about that our
concern is about individualized records
that are at threat of being
disclosed and there there's no valid
purpose for doing so but aggregate we we
have no concern sir
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
in new hampshire
this was turning in the glue but i'll
say it again we have a strong
long tradition of privacy
so strong in so long
that we actually built it into our
constitution
how many other states out there have put
into their constitution to the degree we
have to protect our privacy
i cannot answer the specific question
sir i do know that the state has gone
above and beyond you know from uh you
know privacy and liberty in terms of
uh surveillance technologies by law
enforcement
um surveillance technologies by the
private sector to ensure that that the
individual rights of people
and their privacy is protected could i
ask paul thank you
i guess the question to
aclu with the resources you have can
someone do a data search for me to find
out how many states out there have in
fact built into their constitution the
degree that we have
to protect our privacy we've taken it
to that degree because it's that
important to us
i'd be happy to look into that sir
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman and this may be
another question that you can't answer
but you seem to know a lot of things so
i'll ask it anyway um and maybe someone
who comes after you will
know the answer
among the 47 states that um
cdc collects this kind of data from
are you do you know at what stage
of that collection
how do i put this at what stage is the
information aggregated
for those other 47 states is it
aggregated by the providers or is it
aggregated
by
a department within the state government
i will get back to you on that sir i do
not have the specific answer for you
here but i'll get it for you thank you
very much
representative leon thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
questions i also share your importance
on making sure that individuals aren't
identified by their data and thank you
for paying close attention to that
when we look at how we'd implement this
obviously there'd have to be some link
for the providers so that when they
re-enter the system it's the same person
if this was implemented with a random id
generator in the system where if that
isn't even seen by the practice that's
entering it and that happens quietly
behind the scenes so that there can be
no link would that address the concerns
about patient privacy while still
addressing potential health equity
issues if if this is disproportionately
affecting certain communities
i i think we are
unsure why the individual would have to
be connected at all and why we would
have to have that step why it wouldn't
be sufficient for the
provider to just provide quarterly
aggregate reports
to the state
that that don't
unnecessarily jeopardize the
follow-up when you're looking at this
data you wouldn't look you wouldn't
necessarily use an average age of 25 or
43 in order to get a good look at what's
actually happening so each of those
individual data points is useful so if
that information when it went in was
blind and simply had a entry number
unknown to the physician and unknown to
the entering person
i don't do you know how that would be
traced back to an individual patient
um
i am uh forever amazed at the advances
breach privacy and so i always urge
caution and ensure that we take the most
cautious steps possible and then minimal
steps to that could
potentially breach privacy in the future
and so
if the concern is to gather data around
you know age race number of procedures
etc
i think that i don't see a need to go
beyond filling out that basic
information at the aggregate level at
that level
and why we would need to even
potentially put someone's privacy at
risk
and again going back to the fact that we
are again talking about a medical
procedure
that is
being singled out for for data
collection
thank you
representative
um no
delemus
can you hear me no
hello hello okay thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question just
i'm not aware of any of this kind of
stuff so are are providers offices
also vulnerable to data breaches
individually
okay
uh yes ma'am i mean anything that is uh
accessible via the internet is at risk
of data breach and i think that's part
of our concern but the way this bill is
drafted is even if it is at the provider
level their their systems are vulnerable
to attack
follow-up
thank you
so
do are you aware if there's anything
being done to protect those data in
those in those offices i i don't know
we have strong uh laws that that uh
dictate how
health records are are to be kept in
uh but again nothing is perfect in
systems you know even you know the
united states government you know the
federal government the department of
defense
you know that have uh some of the most
sensitive data you know that one can
think of have have have breaches um you
know nothing is perfect no system is
perfect and so i think again that that
that is why i urge caution at the
collection of individualized data
particularly without any type of
sufficient need and so i would urge the
committee to
think think carefully about the need to
collect that information versus the
aggregate
seeing no one else thank you so much
thank you sir
the chair calls dr psycherella and
chairman pearson members committee john
williams legislative director for the
department of health and services
uh for the record dr sacharala i'm the
bureau chief for the population health
and the division of public health
and dr charles is going to get into some
of the the details of some of the
concerns we have but i'm just going to
leave a very brief um background since
i'd worked with this committee on a key
bill starting back in 2014 which was
house bill 1502 this bill was put in
interim study and worked on like you
couldn't believe uh in terms of going
through the mechanics of this particular
proposal uh for those members who came
aboard with us in 2016 they may recall
one of the first bills they took on was
hb 629 in 2016.
that was a bill that came out of that
interim study committee that had been
worked on um in in pretty great detail
the bill was passed by the house but
tabled by the senate and there have been
a couple iterations of bills including
the one that represents stapleton who is
a delight in joint although he's not
here for benefit of the comments uh to
work with when he was on the committee
um
but um
identifying those bills as we've made
our progress so some of the questions
when you ask questions of the department
why is it so
historically i'll be relying back on
we've gone down those conversations
before i know that representative leon
you had brought up regarding additional
data points such as race race and
ethnicity and there are when you look at
our
companion states like the state of
vermont those were data elements that
initially then bureau chief tricia tilly
now director of public health tricia
tilly working along with myself worked
very strongly on to make sure that the
data that we'd be
receiving would be helpful and
meaningful however as a compromise
working over many many hours it was
decided that the group of data points
that's identified in this legislation is
essentially what was distilled upon at
the at the end of the day so i'm not
here to reopen those conversations but
historically to explain why
they're not included currently in the
proposed legislation
i would also like to say to represent
merchant who i do not see in the room
on the constitutional issue that the
concurrent resolution 11 that passed in
or 18 that eventually became part 2b of
new hampshire's constitution around
privacy actually occurred after
the earlier work that was done on the
prior bill so i'm not prepared to
responding on how that may relate on a
constitutional level
to the current legislation before you
because quite honestly those issues
weren't even uh ripe at the time because
of the fact that there was no provision
under the state constitution to do that
particular analysis uh so with that said
probably uh um notwithstanding some of
the clinical pieces from a data point
and statistics that dr trell is going to
get into i'm going to mention the one
thing that you hear me state on about
every other bill if you do want us to do
this you do have to fund it and that
would be our respectful request of the
committee the department did identify
the need for a position to do this work
in the bill it has a fairly modest sum
of a little over a hundred thousand
dollars respectively for each respective
state fiscal year including benefits it
does not include
certain systems related changes that
we'd be required to make as a
requirement to the statute we do adhere
very strongly to safeguarding
information and protecting that
information and so
that piece of the work would need to be
done there's also a contracting piece
that we would have to also be involved
with so this bill currently does not
provide an appropriation for the
department to do that um we don't we
also did not have the benefit of the
draft
amendment that was proposed to the
committee
and at least nothing physically in front
of us to be able to respond to but i do
know from what i heard from the
testimony we are concerned and i see
our one of our members of our agency uh
chawe chirala who is with us in the
audience who um all who brought to our
attention that we specifically do not
want to look into amending rsa 126
regarding health statistics
uh which is we which be a new wrinkle
that's not identified in the current
legislation you may recall and and
represent mcmahon was a co-sponsor uh
for a bill that we worked very
diligently to clean up our health
statistics statute working with this
body working with the department of
justice and others back in 2019 and
senate bill 1-1-1 so we would like to
keep that in place without looking for
further amendments to that section of
the bill as a technical uh challenge in
this bill you'll note that there's some
in turn there's at least one internal
consistency issue that i'd like to bring
to the attention of the committee
knowing that this is going to be worked
on so we'll keep our commentary brief
that on page 2 starting on lines 22
through lines 27 it starts off with the
initial
reporting requirement from the
department on january 1st and then
you'll see it has to be posted on our
website no later than june 30 of that
year
correspondingly there's the same
provision that deals with the annual
reporting requirement on the same date
of the bills starting on line page three
line ten
and i'm focusing specifically on
the first new paragraph roman
3a not the section b
below but you'll see that there are two
specific sets of data one that the bill
the underlying bill as it originally was
worked on by this committee over
more than half a decade a worth of work
is reflected in the laundry list of the
data that we're going to report on the
upper sections this has us reporting on
the current procedural terminology
otherwise known as cpt codes and also
the s codes that you'll see
as well it's
at a minimum these two sections will
need to be harmonized because you have
two different reports essentially that
the department's doing so they really
need to be brought together as a single
report if the legislature directs us
doing this also it's interesting that
you may recall for those of you who are
here
on one of the prior very recent prior
iterations of the bill that this
committee did um
i believe brought forth some type of an
amendment that dealt with the cpt code
so this is not the first time that we've
seen this i'm looking around for
institutional knowledge for those who
were on the committee in the last couple
of years that we expressed concerns
regarding it one from a drafting
standpoint that it's unusual putting cpt
codes in statute and so it might even be
better to more appropriately identify
what information the that the committee
would be interested in the legislature
would be interested in us collecting uh
i will say dr trella is kind enough she
does have the secret dakota ring of cpt
codes if you're interested ever in
finding out what these mean and we can
certainly provide it to you after after
this hearing
um so the other last comment i'd like to
make before turning it over to dr trala
is we work very collaboratively with the
department or rather i was going to say
the department of state but the
secretary of state's office and
regularly they could not be here with
you today because a large share of the
questions that need to be entertained by
this committee deal with the
safeguarding and the collection of data
the vitals records otherwise known as
the new hampshire vital records
information network is housed not with
the department of health and human
services which is slight anomaly because
in most states i think pretty much all
states that vital record is housed with
the public
health division department
in our state it's housed with the
secretary of state's office again we're
not here to try to suggest taking on
more work than we need to do but it is
the reason why we're very limited in
terms of thank you for not putting that
amendment forward uh that we're very
limited in terms of what we can respond
to relative to uh safeguarding of their
information we can talk to you about our
safeguarding and i talked to dr sorella
anticipating the question to her
knowledge we've not had a data breach as
to our system since her tenure here in
the department so dr charles turn it
over to you thank you
i think john covered most of my points
that's the reason i keep john on the
side so
thank you for giving us this opportunity
to speak and one of our top priorities
for the department is
is the health of mothers and babies with
our objective is to promote healthy
pregnancy early childhood and as well as
looking at how do we reduce unintended
pregnancies especially in teens because
that's our one of our priority areas but
what we understand is we if we want to
understand how the pregnancy is we need
to understand all the outcomes not just
one place one one kind of area and we
get we want to use this information to
want to see what kind of targeted
prevention both the primary prevention
public health prevention as well as
clinical services that we need to
provide this should include the family
planning as well as any kind of
reproductive health care and this should
be for all new hampshire residents not
for certain groups not for some some
people but all new hampshire residents
given this context we have some really
serious concerns about the current uh
bill as it is this ties back to some of
the data collection pieces some of the
privacy protections and also the current
alignment that we have with our current
rsa statutes as well as our rules in the
our administrative roles so has john
pointed out we have some issues about
data collection piece uh validation we
can do any kind of validations preparing
and some of the most important pieces
some of the providing some of the
education to health care providers how
would that tie back to some of that work
and we do not have an appropriation this
would be an unfunded work for us and we
do not have a capacity to do that work
and there is currently an rsa statute
and rules that actually provide a
structure on how we share data with our
division of vital records just to
remember department is very different
from the division of vital records so
how this data is shared is very clear so
and it's also limited currently for our
birth death data marriage and divorce
and few other things and we do not this
would be a new data system that would
have to be come under that and has john
pointed out there are two different
systems this legislation is talking
about or this bill is talking about one
is the new data system that has to be
created and the other is the existing
hospital discharge data which is very
different so we have to be very clear
about what exactly these two are as john
pointed out marry these two systems so
that we have one clarity on what those
things are
this also means that we would have to
change some of our existing rsa status
again rule changes
and most important for us
the high priority for us is the safety
and privacy of our healthcare providers
as well as our patients and we are
worried and we are very concerned that
this whatever however the legislation is
written it will still evidently impact
the privacy of our patients and our
healthcare providers
and as um representative leon mentioned
we are very interested in uh other other
additional variables like race and
ethnicity as well as other social
determinants of health as well as the
maternal mortality because as i said we
are not just looking at one outcome we
are looking at understanding the
pregnancy and health
um and the final and the most important
concern we have is around how does it
align with the current or recently
passed fetal uh the fetal life
protection act because in that there is
a specific section talking about
reporting from the providers and how
that ties back to that and how would
also that tie back to some of the
criminal penalties tied in that rsa
statute
so in closing one of the things that i
do want to have
put very be very clear is
we do not have a capacity or funding to
do this work
and there are high high
uh issues or multiple concerns around
the privacy of the people who will be
getting this information who will be
providing us this information we have to
think about that so we want you we want
to bring this concerns to the to this
committee to understand those these are
the things that we need to think about
so thank you for giving us this
opportunity and we are here to answer
your questions
representative leon
thank you mr chairman thank you for
being back in front of the committee i
always love talking data with you
my question is to the idea of
aggregating
putting aside all the other questions
looking
if we aggregate the data at the provider
level where there's a very there's a
limited number of providers who provide
this service in new hampshire if we have
those aggregated information
versus having it
with each of those entries how does that
impact data analysis when you're looking
at 24 or 36 or 12 different aggregated
data points versus however many
individual data points we would have
um
i i will try to answer that but for this
question i might have to turn back to
our our other bureau chief
miss charway chavla she is the data
expert not me
but uh just to give you the background
we already have a hospital discharge
data that comes to us that could be
another system that could do that but
creating a new data system with that
kind of an aggregate level we don't have
a system to take that into account some
and uh mr williams if we could have a
cosign on the pink card
thank you yes please yes so to receive
aggregated data that means that we have
to fully trust what data is submitted to
us so that means that the state or the
agency may not have a way to validate
the data since it's aggregate level and
then if we are not going to be able to
identify the provider then we are not
able to
validate as well which provider has
submitted data to us so we need to fully
trust the data that is submitted to us
if it's in an aggregate format
this is the chair and as the husband of
a primary care physician i am very
appreciative of your desiring to
uphold their privacy
but i couldn't help thinking at
dr sai that
many of the questions you've raised
about what about this and the concern of
that and hipaa and all the other things
obviously haven't they not
must have been addressed by 47 states
who are doing this in some way or other
so i'm sure there's you don't have to
reinvent the wheel you can find out what
they're doing in all kinds of different
states and that should really inform
those questions which were appropriate
very appropriate questions that you
raised do you think
i think they i understand where the
question is coming from representative
pearson chair sir uh but the question is
also like 47 states have done doesn't
mean that they have done it in a vacuum
they have done it with their with the
process in place and
here that the bill which is asking us to
do is two different things there is a
totally different electronic system that
is being created under a different
department which we do not have any any
kind of control so that's a question for
us the other piece is yes some of these
things are important but the privacy and
those protections are in the different
places each state have a different kind
of take on it so those are some of the
things that has to be worked out in our
state
thank you
thank you and i think you have touched
on this but i want to be sure am i
correct in understanding that
with respect to data collection the
first problem is that
the bill as drafted setting aside the
amendment
requires the use of the new hampshire
vital records information network which
does not collect
medical data it collects
birth death
divorce statistics
and
is not under the
not under the control of the department
is that correct yes that's accurate okay
so
so am i correct and thinking the bill
would have to be revised to provide
for that issue that's number one
follow-up i would
i would depend on the committee what the
decision is being made yeah fair enough
uh follow-up
yes if
we are collecting this data in the
department
do you not need a whole new data
collection system and was the whole new
data collection system part of the
process when the cost of implementation
was figured out
for this bill no because this bill was
very clear that the system would be
sitting under that vital records so we
kind of looked at what was our cost and
what would be responsibility from our
end we haven't put the cost around if
the data system sits under us
and and the final yes again
if you know and you may not know um
does the
system in place at vital records have
the ability to generate
the kind of super secret numbers unknown
to the provider an unknown to the health
department
that
representative leon was talking about or
would that also require a system we
don't have in place at the moment
that would be a question for the vital
records than us i i don't know all their
data systems per se and what kind of
behind the scenes they can do
so that would be a question to for the
the secretary of state and could i have
one one
one more um
and isn't it true that the purpose of
the vital records department
is to collect records that are actually
intended to be public
at least under appropriate circumstances
as opposed to collecting information
like people's birth and death records
uh as opposed to information
like medical records which is supposed
to be completely and utterly private
i can speak as a medical provider and a
primary care provider yes that's the
intention that all our medical records
would be pri
be protected um again the intent of the
vital records for birth
death and others i think again they are
the ones who can comment on that and
what kind of protections they have in
place that's fair enough thank you
representative
thank you very much for taking my
question i just want to check you both
discussed the question of validation of
the data that that would be difficult to
do
is the concern there just sloppy
reporting or false reporting
or both
i would say both because given some of
the things that any kind of data system
takes time for both the education of the
providers as well as getting an accurate
data to reflect on it and understand
like where the gaps are and how do we
educate our providers on getting the
right information so our concern with
that kind of things is both those two
issues
thank you chairman pearson
thank you for taking this question and
and this is going to be
educate representative folsom
how do you go about
collecting the data say on how many
people have had heart attacks in the
state or how many people have had
uterine cancer or breast cancer or
[Music]
a variety of different health
issues that you can go online and read
all kinds of statistics about
how do you collect that and keep it
private
i um thank you for the question um it's
an education for all of us we learn how
to go so um
you had a very good question about
cancer
we have a state cancer registry which
collects the incidence-based data so
whenever any new hampshire residents get
diagnosed with cancer the hospitals are
places where they get diagnosed we get a
report so we follow that and we
understand where their diagnosis
happened what is the kind of diagnosis
and what kind of cancer and all that so
we have a
cancer uh registry and that's an rsa
statute that covers that
for the chronic diseases we do not have
a registry but we use our hospital
discharge data to understand what's the
prevalence meaning how many people have
that at that point of time
we also have what you call has behavior
risk factor surveillance system which is
can you repeat that please
behavior risk factor surveillance system
it's called in short brfss so these
these are also
these are national level and these are
telephone based uh surveys and these are
called uh people
people get called and they provide like
they are asked list of questions do you
have diabetes and all that and these are
all again people give permission for
those questions to be asked and to be
surveyed basically
so again that's a that's again a
prevalent system basically saying in
this in the sample for new hampshire
this is the number of people who got who
have a diabetes or who have hypertension
i mean high blood pressure so those are
some of the things we do not have we do
not create registries for the sake of
registries we kind of create them for
following some clear
understanding some high risk issues like
cancer because we know that requires
understanding we need to know what kind
of treatment are working what kind of
things are working and we try to
understand what the lifetime risk
factors are so we create those systems
for that purpose
follow-up
um if uh if a system existed that um
was reporting
abortions and also reported
the types of um
contraceptive methods that were used
would it be able to then provide some
information on better preventing
unwanted pregnancies therefore
avoiding a medical
procedure
[Music]
yes yeah i would say yes but again
that's a creating a system means
basically
you asked about cancer registry
currently the cancer registry system
costs around a million dollars
we get federal funding to support that
one we get a small percentage from
general funds but very small but we are
dependent on federal funds to run that
kind of that systems so again there's a
cost involved when you're looking at
this
data for the collection of data is good
but it also needs some it needs a
purpose and what are we using that for
where are we using this information and
how it could be utilized for other
things we are always public health
people population health people we love
data so it's all about looking at how we
can avoid where are the gaps what kind
of social determinants of health are
impacting people so that's important for
us but we also understand like you know
where where is our written on investment
where do we need to put our resources to
get the better results on you know not
only looking at outcomes but also where
is the health gaps are so that's an
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
you may not
the question i have is that
i've become aware that something from
the state of new hampshire in the
insurance department called all all
payers claims data
and my understanding in that data there
is the cpt codes
that we're talking about here so are we
reinventing a wheel
the all-player schemes data does sit on
the new hampshire health insurance
department we do have
again for access purpose we have
specific protections in place
i'm looking at john because again that's
a different department and they would
have a better
answer for that question yes we do have
arrangement through our division for
medicaid services as it relates to what
they call chis the comprehensive health
information system which is are
receiving that information from the
department of insurance um we really
would have to put our hat on and really
think through how that might be utilized
for the purpose of the underlying bill
uh i this is a first occasion over five
plus years of thinking we've chatted
about everything about the subject
matter uh so i can certainly um have it
looked into by attorney rob berry and
also don landry who's in the audience to
take that back to see
what if anything could be done around
that but i do want to say that that
claims data would be limited to a
certain population not a statewide
population would be my understanding and
looking back at dawn for a little nod to
say that would be correct in terms of
chiz would only be medicaid
that's a yes that i see
follow-up
but as i understand this are we talking
about the data sent from the insurance
department over to dhhs which is a
subset of the large database
with the larger database in fact have a
richer
number of
data points that we could pull across
instead of just looking at medicaid
and respectfully mr chair that would be
a question for the very knowledgeable
tyler brannan from the new hampshire
insurance department he would know the
representative king
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question which is
actually going to be directed at john
mr williams counselor
there's been a couple of references to
funding and
and this is just my naivety about um how
these bills work
uh there is a fiscal note attached to
this uh with 139 300
in 23 20 and then another
similar number 24
and about that same number and 25
is
that just not enough to cover what you
had mentioned earlier a wonderful
question thank you so much for for
offering that representative king
that is a confusion that executive
branch agencies have as much as the
legislative branch that just because of
bill has a fiscal note identifying the
cost that does not fund the program
there actually has to be language
contained in the bill itself to provide
an appropriation of an appropriate
amount you'll also see under the
estimates and those were just for the
staffing costs salaries and benefits not
to include other costs that are would be
related to this but you'll see that
underneath there it said the another
agency
did not have an opportunity to provide
well they did have an opportunity they
just well you can read it
and so we can't defend that because we
submitted our information
but if you'd like to see a snapshot of
what it might look like i'd already
mentioned a couple of prior bills that
were out there and they did identify in
their fiscal note sheet it was
definitely in the six figure range the
lower six-figure range between 100 and
500 000
but if you were to take a look at uh hb
629 from
2016 or hb 471 from 2017 again hb 2 629
hb 629 from 2016 and hb 471 from 2017
that will give you at least the cost
estimates based in that magic moment in
time and maybe you can extrapolate from
that what those costs may be but knowing
that the secretary of state are
wonderful people and they respond to
particularly committee chairs who ask
for information i assume you'll be
getting an updated information on those
systems costs thank you represent king
and i'm looking forward to their
response
the chair calls jason hennessy new
thank you mr chairman my name is jason
hennessey i'm the president of new
hampshire right to life which is the
largest pro-life organization in new
hampshire we represent thousands of
pro-life citizens
i also have a phd in computational
sciences and statistics and i'm also a
resident of amherst new hampshire
so we're here to enthusiastically
support hb 1654.
so
new hampshire takes an extreme position
on this we are one of only three states
that does not collect abortion
statistics
it's interesting because you can go to
the state website and find statistics on
all sorts of stuff you can find it on
heart attacks asthma
stds
copd
but you can't find it on abortion
so
right now the way the system works is
that we have to depend on voluntary
disclosure
uh
and then and and it's only they're only
incentivized to do that when it suits
their needs and i'll give you an example
um a couple weeks ago in here in the uh
actually in the state house
over there at the hearing for sb 399
um the commit the senate judiciary
committee asked the ob gyn chair of
dartmouth hitchcock how many
to quantify the number of late term
abortions and the answer and i quote uh
it would appear that this is a small
number was the first quote the second
one was i would project it is not many
women at all who seek those services
and so as far as the legislature goes
how are you supposed to make decisions
if you don't have the data you know is a
small number to dartmouth 5 is it 50 is
it 500 it's a 5000
i don't know they see a lot of patients
so
um the fact is that you as legislators
don't have access to this data to make
decisions and you guys have been hearing
all sorts of bills this year
on on late term abortion and other
things
the second thing is
from the science perspective so
uh in my in my in my past as a graduate
student i was the informatics
coordinator for a large federally funded
study
we had to comply with federal laws so
for those who don't know what
informatics coordinator is
it's not very common so i don't know why
you would
it's the person kind of in charge of
designing the system to keep track of
all the data and so i was in charge of
designing the system and and complying
with federal laws and in terms of
protecting it
um
and so
something so something i want to bring
your attention to is that this data is
would be
absolutely
vital for doing for doing science
um covering abortion so so depending on
which end of the
pro-life or pro-choice spectrum you're
on if you believe if you are pro-choice
you probably think that abortion is
healthcare
and then there's no reason not to
collect this data because we collect
data on all sorts of things that are
part of healthcare
and if you're like me and you're
believing you believe in the personhood
of the unborn
these records are
similar to like birth or death
certificates and so regardless of which
end of the spectrum you're on
you're going to think there's a there's
a really good reason to believe in this
um so the way that the way that this
works right now prevents scientists and
epidemiologists from hosting a ton of
studies and and smart scientists come up
with all sorts of questions
that we can't think of um
and and they discover all sorts of good
things uh just a couple that i could
think off up the top of my head was
looking at the incidence of teen
pregnancy
what percent of pregnancies are aborted
uh are there certain geographies in new
hampshire that are affected more than
others
or
even things like are there are there hot
spots where there are fetal anomalies
that they get aborted and we we have no
idea that it's going on because there's
no sort of central record that we can
use to analyze this data so there could
be there could be environmental effects
another question is are we in line with
the rest of the country
so
you'd have to take my word for it
the pro-choice guttmacher institute in
its 2015 uh
statement on
titled abortion reporting promoting
public health not politics states three
states do not report any basic data on
abortion incidents and patient
characteristics to the us cdc
uh it then say says these gaps in state
abortion surveillance have hampered
efforts by the cdc to compile complete
abortion statistics at the national
level
um
and then they they go on to say to
address these challenges
abortion surveillance systems should be
strengthened as needed in states where
they are not where they're already in
place and created in states where they
are not so that's not we pro-lifers
saying that that's the pro-choice
research folks
in terms of privacy so another hat that
i've had in my in my
varied career is i'm a published
computer security and privacy researcher
and and advocate and so and that's
actually a big part of the reason i love
living in new hampshire is because uh
you guys do things like
uh opt us out of real id and stuff
so um in line with best practices having
a three-tier system of decreasing
knowledge is exactly what this bill does
so this sets up three three tiers so you
have the provider who has all the
information
you have the the state which has
uh de-identified information and then
and then you have the the the public
information and at each level you're
losing information
and that is the best practice is having
only the providers can actually decode
who these
uh who these folks are and that's
exactly the way we want it
um the the system produces little risk
as a state only receives de-identified
data to di to
um to re-identify it
you would then have to go back to the
provider who has all the information
anyway
so this doesn't so this bill does not
create risk
where it wasn't before if somebody can
break in
to the providers they can get all the
information including you know social
security numbers or health insurance
whatever
the state doesn't have enough
information to reconstruct this stuff
so that that's a really important point
um
um so to be honest actually the the
biggest risk to the to the to
de-identifying these people is not
through the system
it's probably more likely through their
phones which are tracking their location
all the time and by the way if that's
something that you would like to not see
um with
but there's also health insurance which
has uh has their own records there's
medicaid
and the provider's own health systems
and these are all these are also all
tracking these things so
the state as i mentioned
only has de-identified data
it is legislatively enforced for privacy
at the state and federal level people
who break in there's big consequences
so uh another another question i've
heard is on uh
do we need an identifier well without it
without an individual identifier we
would have we wouldn't be able to answer
questions such as are abortions focused
within a certain population
or you know is it spread out evenly are
there few people doing a lot or are
there a lot of people having a few um
these are all good scientific questions
um another one i'd like to address would
be
why have they uh why not have the
providers aggregate their data
and as a statistician i can tell you
that this severely limits the tools we
can use so there's all sorts of
predictive modeling
and analysis you can do
on the data that if you have if you have
individualized data that you cannot do
if you just have
you know a number that's aggregated
before
um and i'd be happy to talk more about
that if you have questions
um
oh in terms of search warrants i heard
about about the potential for going back
to the providers so i would draw your
attention to
which is the third page
uh line three it says this data shall
only be released to the department as
authorized
uh by this section
and then at the very end it says the uh
the confidential number or any other
personally identifiable information
obtained under this paragraph shall be
for statistical purposes only
and therefore be exempt from disclosure
under rsa 91a so
i'm not a lawyer but it would be my
belief that this protects the data which
uh this would protect the data from
being served with a search warrant but
again not a lawyer
[Music]
so another thing is that somebody said
oh well you can just go back to the
provider so nothing in this bill
requires that providers persist their
medical records
if they want to preserve privacy they
can limit the records like many
companies do so a lot of companies limit
it to like three years or something for
records retention
um
and addressing representative merchant
uh
in part one paragraph g this this bill
and
and that's
and that's my testimony so we we support
this bill and
i'm happy to take any questions
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
so
when i look at the bill now if i go back
if we're trying to really collect the
data
and the aggregate
i'm losing
an understanding of why we have to have
the health care provider identified
number two
on line number 24
once you link a patient confidential id
code you're creating a patient
identifier
and that in my opinion is a
reaching if you will back to the
constitution of our country is that we
have now a patient identifier so
would you as a organization still be
able to use the data without having the
provider and the patient identifier in
there so so thank you for your question
representative merchant um so
right now we have no data any data would
be better than no data
um
however
i guess i guess as a
as a privacy science privacy researcher
and
statistician um
you know
to to re-identify that data from that
identifier you would have to have access
to the provider anyway
and they already have access to
everything
follow-up
thank you mr chairman and thank you if
they can follow up
in lieu of having those identifiers what
i've heard some other data elements
which seem to be more important to
long-term longitudinal data such as
possibly their age certain other things
that are in there maybe the status of
economics or whatever maybe demographic
data
would that be as important and could
that suffice on what you're trying to
get to as far as trying to
long-term trying to identify
trends that we have within it trying to
identify the population that we're
trying to
target versus trying to get down to the
patient code of the provider code
um so could you clarify when you say
patient code or provider do you mean the
cpt codes are you talking about
going back to page one
on line
13 and line 24
if those were deleted
and we still maintained
some of the other demographic code would
help us long term
understand what's going on within our
state to help us
from a medical point of view target
maybe certain targets of population with
education whatever it may be to again
help them with
either preventing pregnancy or dealing
with a pregnancy if you will
thank you for your question
representative
so
again
any data is better than no data
so if we can get any data that's better
but but there are many more powerful
tools you can use in the statistical
anyone else with a question from mr
hennessey
representative leon thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question uh the testimony now has opened
up some new
new areas of investigation so the the
one that we heard about the the chis
they actually already have a way to
de-identify and have an encrypted
patient keys
so would you would you
believe would you believe or would you
think that taking a system that's
already in place within the state of new
hampshire would be the right way to
follow this and do you know if
any abortion statistics are collected
with that or if they are somehow
excluded from the all payers claims
database
uh thank you for your question
representative leon um
so
you asked a couple of questions in there
so i'm trying to keep them straight up
could you i guess first one is if
there's already a way to have an
encrypted double encrypted key patient
identifier so it needs to be broken
twice would that be a protection of
um i would have to see the system
because cryptography
is can be complicated so i don't know if
that i would be able to say answer that
right here okay thank you and then the
other one was if you were aware whether
or not the all payers claims database
that's supposed to capture all
procedures is capturing these procedures
or not
i i believe that would be a question for
the agency but that is a great question
and and if it's possible to piggyback on
something else that's already working
thank you so much for your testimony
and
i've asked representative merchant to
chair
a group consisting of representative
stapleton the prime sponsor
representative leon representative king
and representative woods and this bill
is going to be exact one way or the
other on the 8th of february that's
our day so uh get back to me with things
if you wish by then
uh representative stapleton if you would
also get the data from
uh abby rogers regarding denise gonyear
who is the new hampshire vital records
system person and or catherine chaney
business systems analyst this is in the
and that closes the hearing on house
1180 relative to state recognition of
biological sex at the request of the
prime sponsor
this bill will be postponed till
february 22nd
this closes the hearing on house
recess thank you
it goes into recess until february 22nd
and whatever i'm supposed to do i'm
now i open the hearing
on house bill 1536 relative to expanding
medicaid
to include certain postpartum health
care services representative
i took murray liberty of walking up here
before actually here we are
again welcome thank you for having me
um for the record my name is
representative megan murray i represent
um the town of amherst hillsborough
district 22.
i come before you
with a bill 1536 fn and in full
disclosure i am also
presenting an amendment for your
consideration though i will address the
bill first
that being said
um what this bill currently does is
directs the department of health and
human services to submit a state
amendment um to expand postpartum
coverage
under medicaid
what this seeks to do
is
that
currently the state provides medicaid
coverage to pregnant women with incomes
up to 196 percent of the federal
poverty level for 60 days postpartum and
it would then extend it from 60 days to
a full calendar year
for 12 excuse me for 12 months
additionally
what this then does
is
effectively provides 10 additional
months worth of postpartum coverage
one of the reasons that i feel strongly
that this would be
a benefit to
women in
new hampshire is that the bill will also
then provide access to other types of
care such as
anything from
for
those additional 10 months lactation
um
urology like if if a woman is having
incontinence issues postpartum or a
mental health care needs around those
issues
and i'm happy to take questions about
the actual bill as well as the potential
amendment for your consideration and i
this is the first time to be fair and
that i've ever come before the committee
with an amendment in hand so i don't
know how to proceed with that
we'll all learn together may i discuss
it and absolutely i don't see why not i
mean that helps us understand what
you're trying to do
with me
okay and so the other the amendment
before you which would be 20 22 0 3 9 1
h for consideration
simply creates some parity um
with another
bill proceeding in another chamber and
i'll just leave it at that
the date on line 11 from october
1st
2022 to august 15th of 2022 as some
stakeholders had indicated that
potentially it could be implemented
sooner rather than later
and then um on line 23 it adds um an
appropriation there for it um and seeks
to
um
define that
with the bill currently so i'll take any
representative folsom
okay sorry
i was trying to do clerk stuff at the
same time you were speaking learning
together here sorry
um
currently
how long is a mother covered after
delivery
for medicaid for medicaid 60 days okay
and
follow up and so this would take it to a
year correct okay thank you you're
welcome
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question
uh for
eligibility for medicaid
for pregnancy and
postpartum
um what are the requirements for that
eligibility
so
currently um the way eligibility i
believe is um
determined is that it will cover
currently up to 130
percent of the federal poverty level is
that answering your question
representative
am i on
um i just wondered what percentage of
new mothers in new hampshire
do suffer from postpartum depression
that is a fantastic question that i
don't know
i don't have um a full answer to at the
ready but i'm happy to dig further into
and i should note that um for the record
like in addition to postpartum
depression there are many other
psychological postpartum issues that
surround a woman
um and post-pregnancy and oftentimes
that is not
60 days is just not sufficient to in
initially diagnose the situation and
then continue to treat the individual
whether it's postpartum depression or
postpartum anxiety or a litany of other
things that might be associated with a
new mom
so that really we're seeking
to try and create the best opportunity
for healthy moms and babies okay thank
representative kenner thank you very
much for taking my question would you
anticipate that this will provide
a significant improvement in both
maternal health and child health in the
state if we can actually get them health
care yes i do
thank you
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
answering this question
um
my understanding is that if
someone was to give birth
and they qualified for medicaid by
virtue of their
income
that
come 60 days after delivering a child
they would likely still qualify for
medicaid
so
assuming that someone's financial
situation didn't change and they
what would this bill actually do would
it change what
what services were covered under
medicaid
that's a fair question i i to be fair i
think that there might be somebody
behind me who might be better qualified
to to should they seek to do that
ex
explain that in more detail
follow up follow up yeah just
i'll wait but i'm just trying to get at
whether
this creates a continuation of medicaid
itself or just the continuation of
certain
services covered by medicaid going
forward
representative gay
thank you mr chairman
uh thank you is
could you correct me if this is wrong
okay as i'm understanding it if the
mother is already covered by medicaid
she would not need this bill she would
already be covered for pregnancy
and for giving birth and for
continuation of care
is it correct that this bill is to cover
people who do not qualify for medicaid
but children do so as a pregnant mom
she would be covered
and up to 60 days
later this would extend that even though
she
children get
medic children
children are covered by medicaid
um i don't understand it would be nice
to understand what the dollar amounts of
income are that put these categories
sure i will allow folks to but my
understanding is to expand that safety
net to for individuals
pregnant individuals postpartum so that
that is looking at
there is an increase in the percentage
of
those between 138 and 196
of the
federal poverty level would be captured
in that
moment so that's what it's looking to
address
could you define that again does this
mean this bill would say that they would
qualify
for
this service
even if they their income was too high
ordinarily to qualify for the mom to be
covered by medicaid this would allow her
income
to be
uh go up to 196
whereas to be on medicaid it would have
to be
under 138 this would be between 138 and
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
presenting this
my question about this is it looks like
there's a 68-day window so somebody who
remains on medicaid remains on medicaid
but adding 12 months afterwards does
this mean that in that 12 months it's
income blind and so somebody who has
really periodic large income
things
can say
have a baby and then the following year
sell something of tremendous value make
half a million dollars or a million
dollars while on medicaid
and then if they have a baby again the
following year be able to turn and roll
this
with making a very high income yet
getting state taxpayer funded health
care i am not sure i'm understanding
your crush but thank you for your
so just to be clear it's it's
10 months of service not an additional
year
so there's 10 more months because
there's already 60 days covered and so
it's looking to extend it for 10 more
months
i would also then
defer your very specific question to
that scenario perhaps to somebody in the
department because i'm not entirely
sure what you're referencing
representative we do have a pink card
filled out by three people probably for
economic reasons and they're all from
yes thank you sir and we're they're all
from the dhhs and
if you like um we can defer those
technical questions to them and happily
do that i thought you might
and are there any non-technical
questions for the representative about
seeing none
now we invite the triumvirate
of
that's a great word dr
sai charla don landry and attorney rob
barry
to
answer technical questions provide
information
the only one proviso is speak right into
the mic please
i will try you're doing a good job so
far so far
good afternoon mr chairman my name is
rob berry i'm the general counsel to the
division of medicaid and with me i have
uh for the
cycle i'm from the bureau of public
population health from the division of
don landry the division of medicaid
services
so i'll be general because the two
smarter people are next to me
with this information but
generally speaking the department is
supportive of this bill we believe it's
an important piece of legislation toward
providing a better continuum of care for
postpartum women
and with that we're happy to take any
questions the committee may have
representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chair um
i think there were some questions about
the um criteria the eligibility criteria
for medicaid but my my question
specifically is
assuming that a person gives birth goes
through the first two months their
income hasn't changed um they haven't
been given a gift of millions of dollars
or
discovered something at a yard sale
that was worth a lot of money but
assuming their income hasn't changed and
they stay on medicaid does this
does this
bill
change the services that are covered or
so it doesn't change the services all
pregnant women get
all services that are available under
the medicaid state plan we just we don't
what currently happens is that when a
pregnant woman gives birth they have
coverage through the 60-day postpartum
and because the income does go up to 196
percent what we do is we evaluate them
for any other medicaid coverage
so in most cases some of them will go to
granite advantage which covers up to 138
percent but those women who would lose
coverage from 138 to 196
they would either
terminate medicaid or they would get
referred to the marketplace and this
would maintain the woman's
coverage in the medicaid coverage
eligibility category
for those 138 to 196 for 12 months
so follow up follow up so i think i
understand
am i correct in in
thinking that you're saying that
for someone who's pregnant
they
the criteria for eligibility is at 138
of um federal poverty level
for the pregnant women category it's 196
percent
okay
so but it goes
after that two-month period it goes
down to 138
correct so they may they potentially
could lose medicaid they could but
but under this bill they would not for
12 months correct regardless of change
in income
thank you very much
and his microphone
oh sorry
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
wouldn't it be possible for that same
woman who
was previously at 196 and that was
dropped at 130. couldn't she go into the
in and out medicaid program for that
10-month period she could and and um
this
option would require us to continue her
coverage through in and out without
having her to meet that spend down
thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
i'm not too familiar with the federal
poverty standards and lines and so forth
but help me understand is the 138 196
based upon one individual or based upon
the family four can you help me
understand because what i'm trying to
get to is that once the child is born
you know you have a family of at least
two
so will that change the percentage of
the income requirements it may not
change the percentage but that will that
change the income requirements for the
mother and the child
yes um so currently the way we look at a
pregnant woman's eligibility for
medicaid i'll just use the example of a
single mom who's pregnant we already
count her as a household or two because
we count the mother herself and the
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
these questions
because i wasn't very clear with the
previous example let me give a more
concrete one let's say you're laid off
from your job on wall street when you're
three months pregnant assume i was a
single mom at that point
i then at four months postpartum went
back to work on wall street so that
would be over the federal poverty limit
would that would i still have been would
i be eligible if that was today or only
for those people who stay below that 196
percent
um
can you say that again okay i'm sorry
income
at first here
laid off income here from until four
months
postpartum four months postpartum income
here again
if i was qualifying for the medicaid
based on my during pregnancy and six and
post 60 months
is it
totally income blind and that in those
additional 10 months or does you have to
stay within that 196 percent no it it
maintains regardless of your change in
income
that would have been a benefit for me
thank you this um hypothetical assumes
people working on wall street make above
so he went with another question
representative gay
thank you
um let's
get numbers again those percentages
if you uh got laid off
then your whatever money that you
got because you were laid off
uh that would have to have fit under the
poverty level i'm assuming one of these
levels
and if if you're laid off and you're
making this but now you're making much
lower because you have some kind of
benefits because you get laid off you
196 percent of poverty so if you're
and then
you're saying that even if
in that 10 months
if we if we pass this and that becomes
law in those 10 months following or the
say the year
following the birth
they would still qualify even if their
income went up that that yes and that's
currently true today in that
from so from a time a woman applies and
she's eligible under the pregnant woman
category or any other category of
medicaid just by virtue of being
pregnant
we cannot terminate her coverage based
on
an increase in her income for example it
would only be terminated in the event
she passes away is no longer a resident
or request coverage herself be
terminated
so really it
it's maintaining the same eligibility
criteria right now it's just extending
the postpartum period from 60 days to 12
months
i thought i understood this so now i'm
trying to follow the bouncing ball i
guess and not doing too good of a job
here
so when the mother
is pregnant she's counted as two
and it's 196.
but once the mother delivers she now has
the mother and the child
whatever reason magically drops down to
138 even though there was two to begin
with
no she's
we look at her
up to 196
in the pregnant woman's category because
at the end of the um
60-day postpartum she's no longer
pregnant we have to evaluate her for
another medicaid eligibility category
and the highest the next highest
category would be
the granite advantage program which only
goes up to 138.
i'm just trying to
i think it's getting a little clearer
i'm not quite sure
um so
the 196
that's because she's pregnant
okay who determines the 196 versus the
138 is that the federal government is
that's the state government where does
that number come from
that does come from the federal
government and the 196 is in our state
plan and we do have a state statute that
sets the minimum at 185. okay thank you
i did see your hand and i nodded
representative connerk thank you very
much um
just to clarify is the reason why
we would not is the reason why it just
simply once you qualify you stay that
way for that extra 10 months is to avoid
the costs
of monthly income verification the
burden both to the patient but also the
burden of the department of needing to
determine eligibility every single month
and that those costs might possibly
outweigh any potential cost of somebody
who has a sudden windfall and change in
their income
is that part of the reason why we don't
worry about doing it month by month we
the requirement to maintain the
continuous eligibility really is a
federal requirement
currently
extending it to 12 months isn't is an
option so i'm not really sure that it
has anything to do with
um
you know the administrative burden on
determining eligibility and that it is
that 60 months is a current
federal requirement
follow-up you know i mean i appreciate
that but is even at the federal level is
that simply because if we impose burdens
of determining eligibility every month
we begin to end up spending a lot of
money on administrative costs rather
than on patient care costs which would
be
you know because you have to balance
that i think we're getting it are people
going to be getting something for
nothing but we also are going to lose a
lot if we do it month every month having
generally eligibility is set for one
month read um i'm sorry one year
redeterminations anyway it's annual
unless there's a change of circumstances
they're required to report
and then we would have to redetermine
eligibility but generally it is an
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you i'm
doing a clarifying question so if a
non-pregnant woman um
gets a large job in a large promotion an
increase she'd be required to share that
information and if she didn't would she
be in violation of the stat of a law
sorry that's the change in status i'm
trying to understand if the person's
required to self-report when there's a
significant change in income
yes they are required to report with
intent any change that would impact
their eligibility for medicaid within 10
days
10 days or 10 business days
i would have to double check the statute
but i can get i'll double check the
statute but i think it is within 10 days
of the change
thank
you representative gay
thank you would that be
10 days from getting a job or 10 days of
getting a
paycheck
i'm going to double check the statute
because it is specific in the state law
of when they have to report it i don't
think it has to do with when they
receive a paycheck but we would ask them
to provide their pay status you know
at that point just to determine if they
still qualify for medicaid under any
program
any further questions for the department
thank you so much
chair recognizes nancy vaughn from
manchester representing the american
good afternoon thank you very much for
the record my name is nancy vaughn i'm
government relations director for the
american heart association in new
hampshire
i do have written testimony and i will
try to keep my comments
to you today brief
but i just wanted to start off
by saying that
the
on behalf of the american heart
association i'm really happy to be able
to be here today to
comment in support of this legislation
so
the american heart association recently
put out a scientific statement on
maternal health um so this this all this
policy is really very timely um with uh
with our support of this in a general
way across the country um but i want to
start by saying that the heart disease
and stroke are the leading causes of
death in new mothers in the united
states um accounting for over one-third
of all maternal deaths um that are
pregnancy related um cardiovascular
disease-related deaths are occur of the
highest between 42 days and 365 days
postpartum
which is why this going from 60 to 365
days is so important
pregnancy-related complications include
high blood pressure blood clots
cardiovascular disease stroke and other
heart problems like cardiomyopathy which
may not surface until weeks or months
after delivering a baby
and again medicaid plays a very
important role
in improving maternal and perinatal
outcomes
timely postpartum visits provide an
opportunity to address chronic and
pregnancy related health conditions such
as diabetes and hypertension
mental health status including
postpartum depression which is very
common amongst
delivering mothers and substance use
disorders while new hampshire has
expanded medicaid and subsidized health
coverage to many low-income residents
it
its eligibility rules that end
postpartum coverage after 60 days can
result in
disruptions in coverage and care
and so again this is really for for
low-income women
who
could very well have risk factors for a
myriad of of illnesses
including cardiovascular disease they
might not know they have these risk
factors it may not appear until beyond
that 60 days when when these women are
about to lose their coverage according
to our current medicaid standards in new
hampshire
so again i highly encourage you to
support this bill
i am not a specialist or an expert on
medicaid um so i'm i hopefully those
other individuals were able to answer
your questions um but basically this is
a population of of women who do not have
any health care coverage at all
prior to
when they are pregnant that is when they
would then become eligible for medicaid
um and then only able to stay on it for
those 60 days while their their newborn
baby is able to stay on its coverage for
for a full year so we really want to
make sure that that the mothers are
remaining as healthy as they can
and able to be a mother to that new baby
so a couple of questions from the chair
number one what is your position with
the american heart association of new
hampshire
my position is government relations
director thank you second one it says
you have handouts have they been handed
i'm putting you into my phone
there
i'm always happy to answer any questions
beyond today as well so
and i have you in my phone now oh thank
you
what's that
a little the chair recognizes
representative leon for what she says is
a little question
thank you mr chairman will you let us
know next time you're here so i can wear
my go red for women pen oh that would be
tremendous and thank you for bringing
that up this friday is um
heart month's wear red day so we
encourage everyone to wear red in
recognition of
yourself as a woman or the woman in your
life or women in your life
so thank you
thank you
and that's all
the
cards so um
it sends the hearing on house bill 1536
but it does not end our day
because we have
four bills
to exact uh representative weber and i
have discussed and
looks like these are pretty
safe bills in other words we can all
pretty well agree on them
and we got to get them out the door so
um just take about a
three or four minute breather and then
come on back
can you tell us what the four are the
numbers i will be happy to
1480.
1537.
oh
on the 11th
uh
oh
ugh
he kept pointing here as if that's where
the state house is see that big golden
dome out there guy
i mean huh
that's not a mcdonald's
okay
is
uh
foreign
um
oh
uh
jerry you didn't come to our party but
we
okay
oh
um
okay
words
i gotta get it straight because i'm the
first one that speaks
hey
man
yeah
1480 1507.
19 and 1537
open the executive session on house bill
relative to eligibility this is an
executive session relative to
eligibility of individuals for
developmental
disability services
and you will remember this bill um it
was presented by
representative abel from grafton county
concerned
about
a
family that was not
at that time getting the help they
should
since that time um the family has gotten
to help at least it's now going on i
and
as i think many of you know i do a fair
bit of work with the dd community out of
the area agencies based in portsmouth
and in atkinson one of my towns
and so i ran this bill by
numbers of people in the dd community
and
all of them came back to me all of them
that came back to me said they don't
this being added and that being added
and that being added that being added
and so on because in their opinion the
general clause that follows any other
condition of an individual found to be
closely related to an intellectual
disability blah blah blah
covers that
and so
yeah yeah so they're good so the dd
people said
very well intended
the individual family has been looked
after but they don't really want the
bill to go forward
so the chair
moves
itl
and would look for a second
representative shapiro thank you
um
representative canark
i just want to clarify because
there was a little bit of a
misunderstanding at least on my part uh
at the end of that session we had uh
spoken about the fact that uh we did not
need to add it because it was already
covered and we had begun to discuss
whether or not we could come up with a
new definition and you charged
christina dyer with getting information
from other states and i reached out to
melissa namath from dhh test regarding
working with her on that
um
i i thought that was to actually work on
it for this bill but as it evolved we
realized that was really beyond the
scope of what we're trying to do here
would not be something good to do sort
of in a rush here and then it might be a
good idea for another year but not here
so i wanted to let everybody know
that that line of inquiry has been
dropped so i am very comfortable with
just moving the itl
sorry joining you on the itl thank you
anybody else
the microphone
i thought that
the bill that we were you know they were
asking to amend
really didn't cover their situation it
was really for
i'll say developmentally disabled the dd
community
very quickly said oh yes um
this familial autonomia
is covered under the broad definition it
was just a little hiccup along the way
nor did they see that this would be a
good time to work on
amending the uh language for broad
categories but they would certainly be
open to working with people who wish to
would the clerk
please call the role
thank you
the motion on 1480
is uh itl
move by me seconded by representative
shapiro
now
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
love
yes representative king yes
representative
yes
representative delemus
representative weber absent
representative mckay yes representative
snow yes representative knark yes
representative salloway absent
representative cannon
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
and we have moved to consent
consent
19 to 0.
and i will write the blurb all right
this concludes the exact session on 14
80.
uh
oh
i was asked to
hand out a letter
from jonathan ruthier
who until last week
was the head of csni community support
network incorporated
they're the folks that look after the
various area agencies
let me hand these around this was just a
letter from him kind of saying what i
he now apparently is has taken a job in
manchester
vice president for operations for the
mental health center i've got more of
these coming which way and the other way
and
save a copy for representatives weber
all right open the hearing excuse me
open the exec session on house bill 1507
requiring child care investigatory
findings to be published in a timely
manner that splits the infinitive
um
i would like to move
20220354 which has been distributed to
everybody
and what does the amendment do
okay during the hearing you may recall
that it was brought up by the people
from dhhs
that on line eight of the bill
this is on one page bill on line eight
it said 21 days that should be 21
business days very important distinction
so the only change on this is that in
line eight of the amendment
it is 21 business days
the other piece that came up that uh i
had asked her about well actually i
think somebody that the sponsor had
commented on initially and i followed up
on
is the question of how do we track
uh and can there be a cross-reference on
an owner or an operator so that if they
just change the name they don't get to
open up a new place and not not be
caught
we don't need to do that that already
exists in rules the license is to the
owner
um it is not transferable to a new
location or new uh if there's a new name
they have to notify
um so the bottom line is it follows that
person so they can't just go change the
name or move it and then escape
detection so we do not need to put
anything in about cross-referencing
because that already is in rule so
that's why the amendment is simpler
than it would have otherwise been
representative canark moves his
amendment zero three five four h do i
have a second
any further discussion on the amendment
i can't hear you can use your microphone
did we have to strike something you said
it's simpler
so what part got struck to make it
simpler did i answer
yes yes no nothing is struck i'm just
saying it's a simple amendment it just
adds the word business
so nothing is struck it just we had
business days
we had considered some other things
right that's what i was speaking about
we were talking about do we need
language to to prevent people changing
the name that doesn't need to be done
because it already exists in rules
already done yep thank you okay
okay please call the roll on the
amendment to house bill 1507 moved by
representative canark seconded by
representative leon
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay yes representative
cushman yes representative folsom yes
representative love yes
representative king yes representative
yes representative delemus
yes
representative weber absent
representative mckay yes representative
snow
representative knark yes representative
soloway absent representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
19-0
now the bill has amended house bill 1507
chair entertains a motion otp
i would like to move otp
bill
house bill 1507 with amendment
5 4 h
any further discussion on the bill
representative acton
okay i'd like to just give a quick um
acknowledgement to uh the deprived
sponsor um
rebecca representative rebecca mick
williams um we did this
back in the study committee back in 1904
covin
and everything beyond after that fell
apart this was the fall and then covert
hit and everything fell apart but she uh
she followed it through and kept at it
and even though she's insanely busy she
can't she came up and this is one of the
big
findings that we had since then the
situation in the department has
has improved dramatically and i've heard
that i checked around some people that
testified with us so things have gotten
better but some things we do want to get
into legislation just to make sure so
this is all overall a successful um
uh episode so are you part of that group
that worked on this yes well thank you
so much yeah we found um we found a lot
of issues but they're they've been
largely dealt with so
wonderful looking good thank you
anything else anybody it doesn't have to
all right
ready
this is house bill 1507 as amended by
moved by representative canaric seconded
by representative acton
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon representative acton
representative gay yes representative
cushman yes representative folsom yes
representative love yes representative
king
yes representative
yes representative delemus
yes
representative weber absent
representative mckay yes representative
snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway absent representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
19-0
representative canark would you write
the committee report please of course
yeah
this concludes the exec session on house
reopen
on house bill 1619 fn
we had recessed this for a very good
reason
and representative canarch speak to that
well there are a couple of things
actually let me kind of catch you up
well what i caught was or well actually
it was called by mike holt uh all of us
missed the fact that it was a wrong
statutory reference it was placed into
uh
126 x 1 9 a
2 and those are that's the list of
symptoms but a migraine is a diagnosis
not a symptom
so i prepared an amendment which is
before you that is 0 3 5 5 that just
simply places it in section 1 which is
the list of diagnoses
now that doesn't mean that i think
that's what we should do necessarily but
i wish to be a good boy scout and be
prepared and have this available should
that be the will of the committee in our
conversation before we recessed it
seemed that the will of the committee
was similar to 1480 not to start making
various exhaustive lists because we
already have
an umbrella diagnosis of chronic pain
and again the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board felt that in its
unofficial recommendation that chronic
pain which includes both persistent and
intermittent would already cover
migraine headache
to clarify the concern of the sponsor
and her constituent had been stigma and
not meaning in this case just a label or
a name
but also the concern about insurance
issues if the records are
pulled up sometime that they'd have a
diagnosis then a chronic pain
i had revealed that they're not revealed
clarified that these records are
confidential within the therapeutic
cannabis program nobody knows what box
you checked to become certified
however the data would be in the
provider's record but the provider can
certainly do this very easily i was a
background
i did back pain
if i was certifying a patient i would
say
in the record not to be deceptive but i
would just say they've been struggling
with back pain now for three years
things haven't worked well and i have
now sent them off to be certified for
therapeutic cannabis
period
so that concept could actually apply to
other issues say abortion for example
records
huh
can let me let me finish this so the
point of the matter is that the
uh you would not then say and i checked
the box chronic pain
because you would it would be understood
that
back pain is a as a pain and if it's
been there a long time it's a chronic
pain so the issue is the word chronic
pain if the constituent is concerned
about that never needs to exist in the
medical record and that's not being
deceptive it's because you'd be putting
down what the diagnosis
would be
so
the
that little bit of a glitch could be
taken care of because the concern we had
was we start adding lots of diagnoses
that then you begin having that slice
and dice thing that we just finished on
1480. the other thing is that
tcmob did not specifically vet this
under migraine because we also know that
migraines have other symptoms and we do
not have a good evidence that we know of
for whether or not it helps with the
visual auras and all that kind of stuff
but it's really for dealing with the
pain phenomena so that that is
that was just the concept and i so i'm
not gonna
i'm not saying we have to do this
amendment i just wanted to have it
available to you all
so it sounds like if we want to keep it
broad we don't need the amendment
if we want to
reference it specifically which it
sounds like we're not so sure we do we
have the amendment in hand
representative merchant
thank you mr chair i'd like to speak to
the amendment
um
i believe first of all i want to thank
the boy scout to my left
did a great job bringing this to the
committee ahead of time just in case we
had to pull it out of the back pocket
but i would go back i think the way it's
worded right now
it talks about moderate to severe pain
goes to modern severe
migraine headaches the word pain has
been eliminated and i do have a concern
with that because by eliminating the
word pain and
inserting the words migraine headaches
it narrows it down to just migraine
headaches for pain not chronic pain
in a total sense yeah i answer that
yes
chronic pain is already a standalone
condition to begin with so that is
covered um i did not choose to make this
a standalone condition because again
there are other features of migraines
other than just the pain but remember to
qualify you have to have section one
and there's the conjunction section two
and section two does have
as a symptom severe pain that has not
responded to previously prescribed
medication or surgical measures or for
which other treatment options have
produced serious side effects
yeah
so the point is
the they would qualify by having chronic
migraine headaches as their diagnosis
and pain in section 2 as their symptom
because it isn't and you have to have
both of those so that's why it's there
how about the question of the citation
can that be handled in enrolled bills
huh
i'm not sure i'm sorry i i do not know
i'm sorry that i'm confusing myself so
good
there's no reason why you shouldn't be
too so i withdraw that yes
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman not that i want to
get home early but why are we talking
about the amendment which we're not
going to use
because we're actually talking about
representative gay
thank you for taking my really serious
question i understand the difference
between uh the this rsa
section well
paragraph one or paragraph two so
paragraph one is medical conditions
right
and
paragraph two
is the one that's first listed in the
original bill
which talks about severe pain that
sounds like a condition rather than
please
yes pain can be a diagnosis or a
condition as well and it is as i say
does exist as a standalone the issue is
that you may have for example uh
ehler-danlos syndrome which is listed on
the amendment on page eight and nine and
that may give you pain so what we're
doing is the symptom is pain sorry let's
keep into this that the hallway the law
was written which has been a bit of a
burden for us over time is it has this
conjunction and you have to have a
condition or a diagnosis listed in
section one
and a symptom that is caused by that
condition or diagnosis
in section two in order to be able to
certify it is a bit cumbersome
um
but that's the way the law
has been written and we did we have
we've tried we've tried changing that in
the past has been have not been
successful
follow up
so we do want to continue we do want to
uh use your amendment so that we now
have a condition no
no no no no can i clarify the issue is i
wanted to be prepared my sense of the
group was they wanted to itl the bill
because it's not needed because it is a
migraine is already included as a
chronic pain so we just don't need to
say it it's that just like we got into
in 1480 adding various things they're
already covered
so you don't need to start adding that
so i thought that was the will of the
committee but i wanted to be prepared so
if i misread the will of the committee i
had this amendment if they instead did
want to add this as a qualifying
condition
so does that mean we leave
we leave the bill as written or just
kill the hope we just killed a bill and
i yes i make a motion to i
representative merchant to make motion
to itl may have it please
i'm sorry i didn't hear you
i make a motion to itl the amendment no
no it hasn't been offered i haven't
offered it yet you can make abortion i
kill the bill yeah would you like to do
that
you can do that yeah because there's no
vote i tl the bill you may do that
without the amendment
say without the amendment right right
correct because
i'll make a motion to idl the bill okay
so move by merchant and i think i heard
delemus second and the motion is
ito
mr chairman who's the second please
sign
yes yes second
any further discussion
representative acton uh just real quick
uh thank you mr chair um the
the issue with with stigma is something
that we can't fix with legislation it's
something that just has to be
worked through its people this is a
tough issue it's been it was way worse
ten years ago when we first started
bringing it up
uh slowly people are adopting this and
realizing it actually does work and it's
reducing the harm of taking more
powerful
pharma
medications and so forth but um i would
just urge everyone to try to
understand that um you know this is
this is real medicine here and it's uh
it's working and it's helping
thousands and thousands of people so um
no just looking at me okay you can do
that i'm pointing at me now too anything
further
the motion before us on house bill 1619
fn relative to qualifying conditions for
the therapeutic cannabis program the
motion before us is itl moved by
representative merchant seconded by
representative delemus
would the clerk please call the roll
thank you
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon representative acton
representative gay yes representative
cushman yes representative folsom yes
representative love yes representative
king yes representative
yes representative delemus
representative weber absent
representative mckay yes representative
snow yeah representative knurk yes
representative soloway absent
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham yes representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative merchant yes
representative pearson
yes 19 to 0. any trouble with consent
anybody shouldn't be good thank you
representative merchant would you write
the committee report what does that do
please
well the old procedure under the
immediate previous two
chairs was you don't leave until it's in
the chair's hand
i don't do that why should you so
and that ends the exact session on 16 19
and the next one is 15
37 i think
and i don't have it
so what is 15 37 15 37 my pirate mental
health okay the pilot
drop-in thing okay thank you i'll find
it's in the pile here somewhere
um
anybody want to talk about it first
representative mckay
um
first i want to talk just briefly about
the 10-year plan
a mental health plan
that's a guide that
was developed by hundreds of people
working over an
extensive period of time
and it outlines every single part
of the mental health system
in
page
31 and 32 of the original by the way
i've asked
john to
get us a copy of the state plan for
everybody here
so that as these mental health issues
come up we have that
and
representative acton and also when we
any day now activate the
uh caucus
and i would very much like to have you
part of that
i'd like to volunteer as a
technical assistant to be able to get
the zooms together
however we meet wow that's exactly one
of the reasons why we've been struggling
with the computer guy you know you're
there must be some kind of an award for
that
she's well-meaning
essentially
this bill
deals with something that's already
happened
the department has been following the
state plan
and has developed a series of
of these peer
focused recovery facilities
essentially the difference between
what is in the bill and what the
department has done
is that she
has she meaning
the prime sponsor
has put in there
a drop-in center
which is no part of
what the
state department wanted
a drop-in center
creates a serious problem
in terms of management because
with most of these recovery centers
essentially recovery
means individuals
who have had a mental illness of their
own
and recover
and therefore
they can be supportive of individuals
who have the same individual who have
the same problem
but that have not recovered
so that
that is a very supportive service
unfortunately
the plan talks about recovery people
doing psychotherapy that they are not
qualified to do
psychotherapy and i would hope that
the
latest rendition of these plans
says so
the
the best use of this support
peer support system
is to work in tandem
with the existing mental health systems
and therefore the department's position
is essentially that
the
recovery system that's
that's in place
be made a part of integrated part
of the existing mental health system
and that's essentially
the only difference from what this
uh legislation would do that the
department has already done everything
else that's
needed
already
that so i'm hoping
that we can as a matter of policy
use that 10-year plan
and
and just as a very quick
comment which has nothing to do with
this bill
the
there's a application to the joint
fiscal committee
for 17 million dollars from the federal
pandemic aid funds
that to provide for inpatient care for
the mentally ill
17 million that's extremely important
also fulfill spagnulo
mental health parity and addictions
equity law
which is over in commerce
deals with
insurance mental health coverage
so that i
move
itl
somebody from the side of the playground
yes representative king seconds
i know this has been said already but um
representative klein knight has brought
several bills this year and previously
and i just want to
acknowledge that um
she is someone who won't stop talking
about the lack the inadequate resources
that we have and i give her a lot of
credit for that
because the resources
are inadequate and um
even though it seems like we itl
most of all of her bills i want to give
her credit for kind of standing up and
saying something's not quite right
when member of parliament william
wilberforce first rose to
um
moot avil that
would end slave trade in the british
empire he got one vote his own
and it took quite a while before he
could celebrate the victory
and i hope she keeps coming back and
polishes it up and talks to some more
folks and so on and so on so next year
we might be able to
otp some of them
thank you for that
any further discussion
doesn't have to be a question but any
the question before us is the motion itl
on house bill 1537 motioned by
representative mckay and seconded by
representative king
would the clerk please call the role
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
love yes
representative king yes representative
yes representative delemus
yes
representative weber absent
representative mckay yes representative
snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway absent representative cannon yes
representative nutter
representative shapiro
representative woods yes representative
merchants yes representative pearson yes
nine
19 to zero 19 to zero got this one down
today
um and representative mckay would you
write the committee report for us please
um
point the order sure
i would just like to um
talk about something that's been on my
mind a little bit and i should have done
it before these bills were executives so
this is exactly the wrong time but we
can go on from here
um
as we all know there's a new mechanism
for signing in
in favor of or opposed to bills
and
so when constituents ask me how they can
participate i've been telling them about
that
and um
i feel badly that when we go to exec
bills we don't take those numbers into
consideration
i think that um
even though judging from my emails many
many many of the numbers will be
opposed to what i'm for
i think it's
the correct thing to do to be more
democratic rather than less democratic
and it's a small thing to just as the
part of each executive
session to announce how many people
signed in for and how many people signed
in opposed
i know some committees do it and some
committees have never done it but i'm
um yeah yeah i i'd have to talk with
lindsay
it's very easy to get it's it's i know
but then we also have to include those
people who signed in on the day of the
hearing so i need to i'll just need to
coordinate that we'll i'll figure it out
how to do it
thank you i think as you you know that
with um rarest of exceptions
um
the bills that we are executing i have
checked with representative weber to see
are we good to go
and since there's that advance notice
and not anything just
on a whim for me
we will have the time to get that
information if people think that this is
a good idea to do so
representative gay
thank you
i need to learn how to use the uh the
information on in gen court
i'm under the impression we're supposed
to be able to even see it
uh
david's saying it doesn't it's very
difficult
you can see it it's very easy there's a
number on top of how many people signed
in favor how many against how many
people uploaded
comments and you can see everybody's
name
so we could add that to the tally sheet
plus like you say the blue sheet
although i am technically not a luddite
i have great sympathy for people who are
illiterate in these matters and if
there's somebody who would like to
like to
get me this information then when it
looks like we're going to exec a bill um
or even now
if the hearing's over we have that
information i don't think you can sign
up after the hearing is over can you
11 59. say it again
you can sign up until 11 59 of the day
of the hearing so they can't until
midnight tonight
okay so everything that we've heard
other than today
is done
and is there somebody who would like to
be um
the person that gets that information
i'm gonna bet that's not why you put
your hand up no it's not um
the reason i put my hand up is that we
asked no i was looking at representative
snow oh i'm sorry
but
why did you put your hand up
well could we ask the researcher
that data is probably there for her to
assemble that information for us i think
one of the things i'll commit about i
want to make a comment on it is
i'm carrying a lot of positive things
from the constituents and the public in
general because all of our meetings are
now being broadcast on webcam or
youtube and so forth and opening up for
greater transparency what we do here
down in concord because it does impact
their lives and i think there's another
data element to it to bring greater
did we just did we close the hearing on
this yet
okay um with that
i closed the hearing on house bill 1537
yeah i will talk to the committee
researcher to have that information in
hand representative snow and
then and his faithful microphone friend
representative snow and his faithful
microphone friend oh yeah my friend
there it is
sorry
the uh fact of the matter is we're still
not getting the names i don't know if
any of the rest of you i've gotten a few
emails over the last few days
you know hundreds of emails as a matter
of fact
and they don't get on the list so i'm
even wondering how valid
the people have bothered to sign in or
what we're still getting a very
small portion of the public's
point of view
in my personal opinion and only that
the lists seem to say to me which group
is
the more active to getting out the
signatures and may not at all be
representative
of what one believes or the public
believes but
those of you who
want me to get that information
um
i will
representative shapiro yeah what i what
i know is that people ask me frequently
constituents ask me how can i
how can i participate how can i show my
support and i tell them about this and i
don't say but nobody will listen nobody
will look at it
so i just feel that we should look at it
and just to give you an example
house bill 1619 which was the
one that we itl
you can just look and it says that 10
people signed in in support one signed
in opposed nobody
uploaded any message
it's pretty easy i'm not volunteering to
do it
yeah um
so it's very easy to do it's certainly
not a headache right no
it it could get a little crazy if you
also want me to add up all the emails
pro and con as well okay
thank you very much
that would be cruel and unusual
punishment then you would get a migraine
yeah
yes represent did i call you i picked
anything to say over there no good
representative leon
thank you
thank you for bringing everybody's
attention to that i did go through all
of the bills that we had open over the
weekend and it is really interesting to
see some people uploaded manuals for
sporting equipment to have an attachment
but it's it's nice to see it's a really
good thing to review and i think it's
the sort of thing that it's good for us
to review before coming into session
we'll end up knowing what the count is
afterwards if we're able to balance
between the in-person sign-ins and that
so that both are reflected but that's
something we should all be looking at
before we come in just like our emails
and those close at the end of the day
of the hearing
so you can go on and
and read them and look at them
also
what is it a heavy percentage of the
emails that come in and say i support
1619 i support
you know we have hundreds of bills and i
don't know which each number thank you
for that and you know so it becomes
meaningless
probably not yeah some committees yes
some committees no representative
cushman
so to make it easier for me to keep
track of what's what i just like
make a folder for each bill
and then i just move the emails
sometimes they address more than one
every email uh yeah early
i'm behind right now but i yeah all of
last year's survival i want to invest
representative gay
today i had a chance to ask the speaker
he was kind of trapped standing in line
to get his food
and so i asked him
uh what why the policy that the capture
is only till midnight you know the day
of the minute before midnight of the day
of the hearing and a lot of times i
certainly don't hear about the bills
until afterwards
uh other people's bills
and so that would be the most
efficient way to get counts and be able
to see them all in one place and we can
certainly tell the people who email us
uh please use that
that that method
but i am going to go ask he told me that
uh
that the right person to be to ask if
that could be extended past midnight
would be to talk to aaron about it
so i would like that would mean i could
participate more too
never feed them after midnight
representative merchant
i came across a cute a cute clip it's
about 15 seconds long i'll send it to
everyone but you can hear before i get
started
[Laughter]
yeah when the spotlight's on
just a nudge folks we got four bills uh
executed
certainly not this committee no
um we could have exact more
bills
everybody but
we're waiting on um possible amendments
to come back
so um
i don't know what we're gonna have
tomorrow i know we've got four bills
they're controversial they're going to
last a long time and we're going to be
meeting here
so
you know keep those cards and letters
coming yes
representative
nothing do we know
and we still plan on meeting on the 14th
and 15th we've got a pile of work to do
so
get it done
may i ask you a question just uh
in terms of our because i don't think
you've said it yet for the seventh and
the eighth
because we have to get everything out by
um and we still have
you know some sec two committee bills we
gotta get done and i think there's even
a couple haven't been scheduled for
hearing yet is that correct
not the early ones not early ones
i think all the early ones have been
scheduled okay i thought i saw a couple
of ones with fiscal notes that hadn't
been that's right i would just
say because we don't want it unless
we're going to bring our sleeping bags i
was curious if we should try to devote
both of those days to executive session
rather than doing any hearings on those
days because we have a lot of big bills
that may take a while oh sorry we only
have two second two committee bills
though my apologies and we've got a
couple of them knocked off it's us jerry
you know you and me yeah everybody i'll
work with you offline
you